Yay.
Yeah.
Freaks this episode of the Joe Rogan's.
Oh fuck it said my name.
This episode of the podcast is brought to you buy naturebox.
Naturebox my new favorite snacks.
Naturebox has this thing called [inaudible] Serratia.
That's how I say it,
right.
So Rochester,
Rochester,
cashews,
they're the best fucking snack I've ever eaten in my life.
I said it the best.
It's an incredible,
they're so delicious.
They have all sorts of cool shit to naturebox is a,
a way where you can get healthy snacks delivered to your house,
to your office,
whatever,
and like,
not tempt yourself with bullshit,
not have like potato chips and nonsense laying around and they can accommodate
specific needs.
Like if you want low sugar,
gluten free,
things along those lines.
They have all sorts of different choices.
More than a hundred different choices,
really fucking delicious stuff.
The big apple pineapples.
Oh my God.
Big Island rather.
Not Big Apple.
Big Island.
Pineapples are delicious.
Um,
uh,
planting chips,
the south Pacific plant,
teen chips,
really yummy stuff.
More than a hundred different things.
Hundred percent,
no trans fats,
hundred percent zero high fructose corn syrup,
nothing artificial.
It's about as healthy as you can get.
When it comes to yummy snacks.
I mean,
they have stuff like pretzels,
which realistically are never healthy.
You know,
it's like fucking doe,
you're eating doe,
but for the most part,
if you want to eat healthy,
they can hook you up.
And if you want to mix healthy up with not so healthy,
you could do that too.
But all of it is delicious and they have free shipping anywhere in the u s
naturebox is a busting the vending machines monopoly on your mid day hunger.
Does that sound like somebody wrote that?
Does a little right in anyway,
go to nature box right now and get 50% off your first box.
That's naturebox.com forward slash Rogan.
That's naturebox.com forward slash Rogen the official snack provider of this
podcast.
So go there and get 50% off your first box.
We're also brought to you by [inaudible] dot com it's o,
n n,
I.
T.
Um,
if you've never tried any of on its supplements,
if you never tried any of on its products and you're like,
what the fuck is this honest?
Should I keep hearing about,
there's a bunch of things that they've discovered.
Scientist,
intelligent people,
researchers,
nutritionist,
things all over the world that can improve various aspects of human performance,
whether it's the way your mind works,
what they call cognitive function,
or whether it's the way your body utilizes oxygen,
the way your brain promotes Saratonin use.
You can actually benefit your body by taking supplements that are the building
blocks for various neurotransmitters.
And that's what Alpha brain is all about.
Alpha brain is what's called a nootropic and this is a very controversial point
of,
of discussion because there's a lot of people that think that anything that you
just like vet claim,
hey,
there's going to be something that makes your brain work better,
bitch,
get the fuck outta here.
That sounds retarded.
It doesn't sound like it makes any sense at all.
I agree with you.
It sounds like horse shit.
But if you step back and you look at,
well,
what,
what is the difference between me on a good day and me and a sucky day?
There's a difference.
I don't know what it is,
but there's me.
When I'm rested and I'm feeling good,
I'm happy.
Everything's in tune where my brain fires good,
like I can have conversations and I flow well.
I'm eating well,
I'm drinking a lot of water.
It works better.
You got to think that everything you take in your body has a direct effect on
how your body reacts.
Number one,
can't stress this enough.
Eat good food.
That's the most important thing.
It's more important than any supplement you can take.
Eat healthy food,
rich in nutrition,
a lot of green vegetables,
all that stuff is a no brainer and it's,
it's number one,
it's the base of the pyramid,
but after that comes the question of optimization and can you get completely
fully optimized through just your food?
I don't think you can.
I think there are benefits to certain supplements and those supplements are the
ones that we sell it on it.
We find things that we find to be beneficial.
We look at the research behind it,
we post all the research behind it with references.
And if we've,
if we tried and we use it and we'd like it,
we start selling it.
All the research is available.
But on it for all of the different,
whether it's all the different supplements,
whether it's Alpha brain or shroom tech sport,
there's the stories behind it,
the logic behind it,
the research behind it.
And we've also done our own double blind placebo studies with Alpha brain and
showed clinically beneficial results.
And we're on it running a,
a much larger study right now.
The first study we did,
it's published,
it's all available at [inaudible] dot com um,
we did it with a small group of people.
It's what's called a pilot study.
They did that,
it was effective,
but for people I think dropped out.
So He's 16 out of 20,
which is really good,
but not enough.
So we're doing a big one now with ADP people,
but the research behind all the individual ingredients in Alpha brain,
all of them,
and you know,
the references to the,
to that research is all available.
All the explanations to the layman a much better than,
I can give it to you myself in a in a commercial,
but the two sort of counter that controversial aspect of these things,
we have a 100% 30 pills,
90 day money back guarantee,
so if you try,
whether it's shroom tech,
which really is like one of the best endurance supplements I've ever tried in my
life and it's all based on the quarter steps mushroom.
If you go and try new mood,
which is a five HTP supplement,
which actually enhances your mood and it enhances your brain's ability to
produce Serotonin,
it's the building blocks of Serotonin,
five HTP en El trip to fan,
which actually converts to five HTP.
All of it explained it.
audit.com and like I said,
a hundred percent money back guarantee.
You don't even have to return the product to say this stuff is what bitch,
you lie to me and you'd get your money back.
Ludicrous man.
That's awesome.
Yeah.
Ludicrous.
Was playing with some on Onnit kettlebells.
Lewdness Ludicrous.
Apparently become a fitness freak.
He is always posted on his Instagram about a working out.
He's got some trainer it takes in the world with them and he just bangs it out
every day like rain or shine.
He's,
he's committed to working out.
It was pretty interesting smart thing to do.
You know,
if you're a rich guy,
no goddamn trainer with you everywhere.
I make sure you get a workout in ludicrous.
You smart bastard.
Anyway,
on a.com use the codeword Rogan and save 10% off any and all supplements we
sell.
Strength conditioning equipment,
um,
healthy foods,
all that shit on it.com o n n.
I t use the Codeword Rogan.
Oh and there's a big sale going on right now.
48 hour sale,
16% off everything.
Use the code word June 48
that doesn't make sense.
June 48 does that real?
Why would they,
why would it be June 48 years or so?
First 48 hours.
So there you go.
That's it.
48 hour sale.
Okay,
so June 48 so go there for one day in 23 hours and 36 minutes and 43 seconds as
of 12:23 PM on June 2nd
do the math bitch.
All right,
the champ is here.
Tj Dillashaw us in the motherfucking house.
Trainer Twain Bang,
motherfucking Ludwig here as well.
Let's get going.
The Joe Rogan experience.
Try my day.
Joe Rogan podcast by night all day.
I've been a lucky man.
I've been able to see some shit in my life.
I've been able to see a lot of shit up close and personal.
I've seen way more than a thousand fights.
I don't know how many I've ever seen professionally.
The best fight I ever saw in my life.
They'll finest performance was this man sitting across the table from me.
Tj Dillashaw,
your fight with Hannah Barao was the slickest,
most technical,
most beautiful mountain that I've ever seen anybody climb the way you did.
That shit was seriously like,
it's no matter what happens from now on to the end of time.
That was a milestone to me.
That was like a guy who rose to the occasion against the biggest drag in and the
fucking forest.
The one everybody was scared of.
Dude.
Hanan Barao was a fucking werewolf.
That dude was wheel kicking people in the face and fucking do it like leaping
knees and pound dudes out,
taking their backs like a ghost.
Just wicked looked wicked at every turn.
Undefeated for like 30 fucking fights.
I mean it was incredible and a brown was a beast and Tj Dillashaw you picked him
apart.
You moved around him,
you looked like you look so relaxed in there for the moment.
You got into that cage.
I go,
look at this kid,
he looks like he's in a sparring session.
You were just loose and move and you weren't doing anything that showed that you
were tense,
you and you weren't doing anything like what?
You're hesitating,
anything where you're like dipping your feet into the water.
It was like from the get go you were in the groove and you could see right away
there was a thing where brown was like,
oh shit.
What the fuck's going on here?
Somewhere in the first couple of minutes before you landed that right hand in
the first round.
Somewhere in those first couple of minutes you could see,
he was like,
I am getting fucked up here.
Like this dude is hitting me and I can't hit this dude and all of a sudden wack
you drop this right hand on him over the top of the left shoulder on the button,
the legs give out.
He goes down and I'm like Holy Shit.
And He survived the rest of the fight into the fifth round when he stopped and,
but he was done after,
he just wasn't the same after that.
And his corner was telling them do not exchange with this guy.
Stay away from the exchanges.
I was like,
I can't believe what I'm hearing.
This is the cra,
his corners telling him to run from Tj Dillashaw.
They're like,
take this fucking guy down,
grab him and take him down.
Which you know,
you would just wouldn't think would be their strategy.
So it was like a clear adjustment of something that was going on in a fight.
Well thank you.
I appreciate that.
Often.
Have a grin on my face the rest of the day now man.
Oh,
you deserve it.
You deserve it.
And more,
you know,
you two together or a very unique combination.
It's really interesting because I've had the pleasure of being friends with guys
like Duke Roufus who's a great trainer and a great guy and Greg Jackson's great
trainer,
great guy,
Mark Tele,
Tammy.
I've,
I've had a chance to become friends with so many of these guys and one of the
more problematic aspects of fighter trainer relationships are like that fighters
are kind of like stubborn and they're,
they have a lot of ego in the effort and so are trainers and a lot of trainers
used to be fighters and a lot of guys have this my way or the highway thing
going on and a lot of other guys don't like to take instruction.
It's a lot of weirdness when it comes to fighters.
It's a lot of weirdness when it comes to emotions after losses.
Trying to figure out who's to blame,
passing blame when maybe you shouldn't.
But every now and then it works perfect.
Every now and then you got like this puzzle where these two dudes are actually
friends and you see at work out great.
And that's why I see you guys right now.
You guys are in this rare space,
you know,
like Rufus has it with Anthony Pettis,
like,
and he's had it with a lot of other fighters that he's trained as well because
he's such a friendly and affable guy,
you know.
And Dwayne you found a way to you and Tj,
the way you guys sync together.
I see it,
you know,
I see when you talk about fines,
I s I had the,
the privilege of a watching you work with them once at my gym holding pads for
him and I was watching you coach him and you guys,
the way you guys move together.
It's real interesting relationship.
Yeah.
It helps out that,
uh,
he cares how I do and that not only I want to win for myself,
but I want to win for him too.
It holds like this higher standard of like what I want to do every day I get in
the gym,
I've got a guy watching me 24,
seven on what I'm doing wrong or right.
And so I want to like not only pleasing your father and you're a kid,
you know what I mean?
Like doing the things right for him.
You know?
It's like the same thing I want to do,
do it.
Dwayne is show me the right way and it's like I'm just got addicted to doing it.
So cool.
It's so cool to see.
I love watching shit work,
you know?
So it's so cool to see you go over to this Alpha male team and then all of a
sudden,
boom.
I mean you got this camp full of killers,
like arguably the best light,
lighter weight camp overall in the country without a doubt.
Top three,
right,
of,
if not the country,
the world.
There's no Uniao does you guys,
and it's you know,
a couple of other places that,
that have that kind of pool of talent and the lighter weight divisions you guys
have it locked down.
Yeah,
there's definitely a,
this is a special time and martial arts history.
Let's go on and right now with the,
the team that was just have with me on the team,
it's,
it's something special for sure.
You know what,
it seems like this is a special time in martial arts history period.
It really seems like there's a lot of energy on MMA right now.
The fact that there was two UFC is going on at the same time on Saturday,
you know,
that was pretty wild.
And I just,
I feel like more people are aware that the highs in MMA or higher than any other
sport is,
you can't compare a ball going into a net.
It's still just a fucking ball going into a net.
And when you hit,
you had kicked tennent brown that fifth round and you saw his knees go and you
moved in for the close or I was like,
Oh shit dominates him for four rounds and he's going to head kick them and stop
them.
This is crazy.
That kind of feeling of being a fan of watching.
Oh a wild fight like that.
It's super hard to describe
and put putting your,
you're putting,
it's Kinda like putting your life on the line when you're in there.
You know what I mean?
Even though it's not,
but it feels like that I kinda,
I kinda adrenaline rush and,
and that feeling of,
once you get the fight done,
there's no better feeling in the world.
Just kind of,
you have to,
you have to scream and go crazy.
I couldn't imagine.
I couldn't imagine I knew what it was like the,
when a taekwondo tournament,
which is
nothing compared to a UFC fight,
especially UFC fight for the world title,
especially the UFC fight for the world title.
When you're an eight to one underdog on the consensus pound for pound,
at least number two guy in the world,
it's like John Jones in him.
They would alternate between one and two and in my opinion,
mighty mouse.
I don't,
in my opinion,
they don't give money mouse enough credit.
He's never in the top four of people's lists.
I think he's,
he could be number one.
I mean he's right up there.
He's as good as anybody in the world.
Awesome athlete for sure.
Perfect.
Technically everything he does is perfect.
The way it,
I mean I always say like young fighters,
like you want to learn how to fight perfectly.
Watch a guy like that.
Watch a guy who was a longtime veteran one time,
been a champion for quite a few fights.
Now he's,
he's as legit as it gets,
but you stepped in there with a guy who's right up there with him.
I mean,
that's where everybody thought.
That's where I thought,
I mean,
I still do.
I still think he's an elite,
elite fighter and you figured it out together.
You figured out a style and a strategy to expose what you felt like were some
areas where he was vulnerable and we actually talked at lunch about the very
techniques that TJ was using,
especially how you kept passing under his left and you were behind him.
Dude,
I was,
I knew that I was a lot faster than him.
You know,
he's,
he's a big one,
35 pounder and he's very powerful,
but I think that hinders the speed.
You know,
I think he,
I think he's too big for the weight class almost,
and I knew that I could be so much faster than him and create the angles that he
wouldn't be ale to keep up you.
He looked lost even in just the first round.
Like he couldn't find me do you couldn't,
he couldn't.
He wanted to like hold me and stop me to be able to kick me or hate me.
This is big right hand,
you know,
he throws the same techniques.
They're just a little bit too slow.
I think
it's so fascinating.
It's so fascinating watching your evolution from the ultimate fighter.
I mean,
I've had the pleasure of watching you from the moment you were introduced to the
world when you started doing the ultimate fighter and you were hungry.
Young Kid,
lots of potential,
but loss of potential and then world champion,
one of the finest performances the sports ever seen and just a couple of years.
That's amazing.
Yeah,
definitely.
That's why I just had a,
my buddy James Blair making me a highlight of just his law is the recent Fred
since I've been here.
And just to see the progression of each fight.
Just Jamie,
load that shit up.
Let's watch that.
Cause it is pretty incredible.
It tells a story.
I'm not trying to give you a big head kid.
No,
I know.
I'm already thinking about it.
Defending the title and half an hour get nervous about that.
You know what I mean?
So you gotta you gotta keep yourself hungry to get better.
And I think that's why I've gained so God's so good so fast.
I agree.
I full full trust in a full,
uh,
knowledge that you'll,
you'll navigate the waters.
So you got to this far too competitive.
You get that big of a head man,
I'm sure you're smart enough to know.
That's the beautiful thing about where we live today is that people you get see
back when like the Muhammad Ali days or anybody before that,
hold on a second.
It was,
it was hard to get like information.
It was hard to watch documentaries and fighters lives.
It was hard to read books on their lives.
You kind of just got stories from old trainers and there was a lot of mistakes
that were repeated over and over and over again.
But at a certain point in time,
in today's Day and age,
especially with the Internet,
you get checked enough so they're getting completely cocky and delusional like
some fighters had gotten.
It's,
it's,
you got to try hard to get that way today because dudes a chippy down,
you know,
and the world expose you.
And there's like really good writers now too.
Who would like,
there's a,
um,
was it Jack Slack?
Is that the dude's name?
Who was,
uh,
did that take down the video?
Uh,
he uses a lot of animated gifts and then,
uh,
talked about your article,
it talks about your fight in an article.
I haven't seen it.
You haven't seen it?
It's fantastic.
Let me,
let me find it.
If we get a chance here while we're watching this,
uh,
this,
highlight and I'll,
um,
I'll give the guy the full shout out and what,
where the website is even watch it because he could rope down the very strategy
that you used and show after,
sorry.
I'm sorry.
With the,
with animated highlights of you doing it.
So explained what he had done wrong and past fights and how you capitalized on
it.
Okay,
brilliant article.
There's an article that came out after my fight after the fight,
but it's so indicative of this new wave of like superintelligent fans that
breakdown fights and super intelligent,
you know,
martial arts analysts,
you can call them fans,
but a lot of these guys have been martial artists their whole life.
They just have another job.
Correct.
So there's still fans of martial arts.
So they choose to write these really brilliant articles on something and you're
seeing just way more info,
more info about what works,
what doesn't work,
and more info about like the,
the,
the mistakes of the past.
Like things that were guys are fucked up.
Let's,
let's take a look at that.
Uh,
that documentary or this a highlight.
She's my desk.
Just got to believe this
my time.
I just kind
perfectly into his fighting style.
Modern Day Ninja.
This highlight reel.
So awesome rocks.
What is the name of the highlight reel?
Watch it.
Cause they're listening to this.
When is it a power of belief?
Yes.
Tj Dillashaw the power of belief,
man.
What a great title for this sort of a highlight reel.
I mean that really is what,
it's perfect.
It's perfect title.
How much do you really believe in one?
Okay,
no doubt.
There's no denying.
Having Bill Rob with the number one
who's the number one pound for pound fighters,
get a
decade of losing the fight to Jake Dillashaw with 15 months.
It's a completely different team.
He was straight Nick Diaz.
Nick Diaz Fan.
That's awesome.
You had nick Diaz and missteps.
I think I've done in my last three fights.
I've just been a huge fan of DSL.
It's so cool.
I love it,
man.
I love it.
Oh,
that right hand was so wicked,
man.
I knew right there,
Louis Louis on the business base.
You know what?
It wasn't like he wasn't swinging.
Dude,
that's still,
that dude was still throwing heavy leather.
He goes in the fight.
He's got a good jab.
You pop my head back a couple of times.
We'll do an awesome job here.
It's hard,
man.
He,
it's very hard.
He's very fast too.
So for you to say you were way faster than him is redonkulous son.
Well I bet you were.
I mean it wasn't just that it was everything.
It was a combination of everything.
It was who he was not one thing that you could tie it down to.
It was your movement.
It was your confidence,
your relaxation in there.
How you look at that.
Just just that series that you just did where you ducked under that right hand
of his and cracked him again.
You were just hitting them with a volume of strikes.
That was preposterous.
He just couldn't deal with it.
It's because of this guy's got me striking it at all angles.
You know,
cell phone were incredible.
No matter where he goes,
I can be able to,
I'm able to strike.
Excellent days,
man.
That fucking picture so awesome to that fixture of you freaking out after you
won,
you just look like electricity was shooting out of your body.
Psychopath does she look so ridiculous?
It's one of the greatest pictures in all of MMA.
That picture of you just
raw.
There's amazing feeling.
I appreciate that.
No shit
man.
Wow.
How old are you now,
man?
28 what does that feel like?
When does this ride like?
It's been crazy.
It's been,
especially for our fastest spin.
I mean,
obviously I pictured myself being the best in the world,
but I never expected it to be this fast and for me to catch on as fast as I did
and when I quit school and thought thought about fighting,
it was just kind of like,
I hope I can make this work.
No,
this is going to pan out.
Seems like it panned out pretty good.
Yeah,
you're,
the crazy thing is you're getting better.
I mean you,
if you can,
can continue at the same pace.
Again,
I hate blowing smoke up people's ass,
but I think you can handle it if you can continue at this pace that you're at
right now,
just the amount of development that I've seen from you in,
from the time you're on the ultimate fighter to the time you become champion.
I've never seen it.
I've never seen anybody improved that quickly.
I appreciate that.
It's amazing you two together or wild combination.
Yeah,
it's a why.
It's a weird combination,
man.
It's because he's so hyper and craziness and then I stay calm and whether they'd
kind of just meshes,
you know what I mean?
Like he's like a hundred miles an hour and I'll like calm down a little bit and
just like makes us perfect or of like
I'm trying to,
I'm trying to be calm right now.
Not me to can I provide for you the relaxed spaceships hover.
You're a part of the whole developmental process though with that madness of
yours,
you know,
cause you're so into like weird.
We were all like,
we went to lunch before your fight and it was me and like five of my friends.
Dwayne didn't give a fuck.
Would anybody else talking about he was,
he was on strategy movement.
He was breaking shit.
That's what I said in all my interviews is because he cares about his job as
much as I do is why this works.
If he goes home,
I'll get home after a hard day of practice.
Right.
Even when I worked at like two,
three times,
get home and just want to veg out.
Watch some TV and like thinking about not fighting at all.
Anything else about fighting and then he'll text me on something I should
be doing for my fight or he watching her brows fight and things I could do in
the fight and was like,
God damn and I gotta I gotta like thinking about the fight go run and like get
all amped up.
It's was like,
yeah,
you're right.
I can't get through that,
so I need to do,
so he's making me think about the fight 24 seven,
which helps me out a lot.
I mean I get in those situations in the fight and he's like,
I've already been there before.
Wow.
That's incredible.
I wonder how long you guys can keep this up forever.
It's so crazy.
Like so manner.
Definitely a good mix for sure.
The best mix.
Hundred percent.
Yeah.
I don't know if,
uh,
if it was kind of a destiny and meant to be,
to make sure like where our paths cross or create your destiny.
If it's already predetermined.
I'm not too sure,
but this is the working out like as if it was meant to be.
Well,
you as a trainer,
you've really fallen into this role.
Was such a passion,
you know,
it's so cool to see because for a lot of fighters they,
they develop all this technique and they have all this knowledge and they get so
much better at training,
but then as they start to get older,
their body just doesn't work the same anymore.
And there's a certain amount of time he can put into fighting and competing when
you know you could Randy coture it if you're a freak,
but he's a rare,
rare dude.
He's a rare guy.
I don't know how he did that and nobody knows how he did that deep into his 40
still competing at a super high level,
just a bad animal,
just a savage.
But for most guys,
at a certain point in time,
they have to find an exit strategy and it becomes a very difficult time for
them.
But for you,
you seem to have found this perfect blend of right when your career,
when you started to slow down,
boom,
you take over the spot about it.
There's very little gap time in between the two.
Like you could take a fight right now,
like if you want to do,
like if somebody offered you a fight right now,
you get,
you're in shape,
you,
you could just do a six week camp.
It's still do a fight.
So it's not like everybody was saying like,
man,
Duane Ludwig's gotta hang up the gloves.
Gotcha.
You were still in the game and you decided to start training fighters and you
seem to have just won't just hit the gas.
It's what I've been kind of looking to do.
I've been training guys since I was 19 anyway.
Um,
I was actually one of a hoarder for Mr. Boss threw in a sense they boss rooting
for is random and fight when he was in Colorado.
So I learned a lot.
Then also,
and I don't know how know us are 24,
25 but it's something I have naturally been doing anyways since I was 19 and the
last couple of years my fighting,
I was just fighting.
It kind of just stay busy and for a paycheck and not to get a regular job.
So if I,
sorry,
I slowed down relaxed.
I get excited,
passionate.
So I know,
I know it's as fast as my brain goes.
So let me think.
Uh,
uh,
it was just if I had this opportunity to do it,
you know,
a couple of years prior,
I probably would have,
uh,
but you know,
it wasn't the right time then.
That's why there's the way that the chain of events that happened,
you know.
Um,
I,
I couldn't actually take a fight.
My knees still pretty jacked up from last fight got blew out.
My knee got blown out.
So it's kind of,
I was in a position where I had three months worth of pay and a year long
injury,
you know,
and then a favorite texts me when I was a cage when Dwayne is a steering number.
And I was like,
yeah,
and then give him the opportunity to come and work with these guys.
And I was handed a parking lot full,
the race cars and asked to take them to the race.
You know,
that's the band.
It's just been an awesome,
awesome ride.
And it's literally like playing a video game.
A hundred percent control controller works
and you hit the right keys on the right.
Right time is literally like playing a video game.
She said to me after the fight and Sir your exact words,
that's how I see it and I'm just a child at heart.
I guess that's a quick,
it's an allergy and I was like,
I know people say I'd like that brotherly love but I genuinely care for my guys
and I love them.
Like my kids have faber's done an amazing,
he has putting together a wild camp of barbarians on up there.
He just kind of draws in these people too.
It's not like he went out searching for all these great training partners,
just his personality in general.
The person he is kind of just like attracted everyone to that camp,
you know,
tried recruiting me when I was in wrestling.
I didn't go up to Davis and and wrestle where he was at after I graduated at
school.
It just kind of,
I just migrated up there.
Munoz kind of pushed me that way,
you know,
and just kind of happen.
Wow.
As long as you can stick it out and be pretty gangster in the gym,
then you're going to work at eight,
you're going to get really good,
you know,
otherwise you're gonna get your butt kicked in.
You're probably gonna leave,
you know,
off enough to,
to good disbarring rooms and we'll throw it down,
you know?
And if you're able to stick it out,
then you're going to get a lot better.
Yeah.
That is the thing.
Whether or not God's can stick it out,
but it's just,
it's amazing that he's been able to inspire so many gods to go to this one area.
And if you know your Ryo,
he's a,
he's a unique dude.
He's very smart,
very smart.
And he's also like super motivated and driven.
You know,
if you read his book is pretty interesting.
And,
um,
one of the things that I talked to him about it when I interviewed him for the
UFC was how he'll write things down and look at them like first thing in the
morning when he wakes up,
we'll have like a list of things that he wants to accomplish,
the list of things he's trying to do.
And like having a guy like that around very inspirational because you want to do
the same kind of things,
copycat method,
you know,
I think he's gotten all that from the book.
The secret.
You kind of learned the way of like setting goals and setting the way you should
live your life and it's just worked out,
you know?
And uh,
this secret is kind of bullshit,
but not,
it gives you,
it gives you the right path I think.
I think it's something motivational,
you know,
it's better than,
it's something created for positive lake,
you know,
likeness on something.
So,
and it's a positive thing just helping people.
So I,
I'm a fan of it for sure.
But I know what you mean though.
It is similar bullshit too.
Yeah.
Good,
good.
Pros and cons to it,
but like anything yet is motivational.
Right.
And anything motivational is good.
If you could find motivation in that to be good.
Yeah.
It's just like it only works on the people that works on,
do you know what I'm saying?
Like for you,
the secret work,
look,
you're the world champion now.
You know what I'm saying?
Like if you could,
if you were in a a documentary on the secret and you were like,
I just knew that I could make this happen and I concentrated on it every day,
and I'm sure I put it a little,
a lot of hard work in,
but the law of attraction is what led you to that victory.
People would go,
oh my God,
the secrets real,
and then it would try it out themselves.
Like saying,
I want to breathe underwater.
I want to be ACO man,
or someone just gonna concentrate on this.
I'm going to make,
no,
you're not going to make it happen.
There's certain laws of physics.
It goes back to the copycat method.
I guess you're just copying someone else that was successful and well,
my point was that it does work in that it works for people works on,
but it doesn't work for everybody.
Like there are people that have started out and really poor families
in bad neighborhoods and they've gone on to become super wealthy and successful
and they've,
you know,
they're,
they're helping a lot of people and starting charities and things.
It does happen sometimes,
but it also happens that people just get fucked over and they wind up in
terrible situations and you can't blame those people that are in the worst
situation that it's all just about the way they thought about things.
Right now you get lucky breaks in life.
So it's sort of a combination of those things.
Like,
yeah,
if you make all the right decisions and you get a bunch of lucky,
lucky breaks and you don't get hit by a fucking truck way,
I'm trying to cross the street,
you can be really successful.
But it's also,
there's a lot of randomness involved in this universe.
You've got to kind of,
if you don't acknowledge that randomness,
people get mad at you.
Like people,
people get upset at you.
Yeah.
Just his overall general message of doing something positive and directing your
life to a certain direction and get the results you want.
Yeah.
It's just when it becomes a system like this,
this will work.
Well that's funny.
Sad cause uh,
you know,
as random finding is but split seconds or fractions of an inch.
I've taken,
you know,
not completely,
but I was able to take some parts of fighting and make it a system and that's
when things that we train off of certain numbers of commands and queues so we
can speak while they're in the cage or on the pants are spying.
So yeah,
that's one of my tricky things in life right now is taking something so random
is fighting it,
putting it into a system so that we can't predict the patterns and you know,
get used to what's coming,
what may be coming next to the counter and or,
or predictive counter and things like that as well.
And this is something that exists in boxing but is even more important when you
add in the extra limbs have more time.
Right.
Like there's more like technique becomes in a lot of ways it's much more of a
balancing act than it is in boxing and boxing speed and athleticism or so
dominating that.
A lot of fighters that maybe don't have the best technique have really good
speed and athleticism and there'll be a more technical fighter who's slower but
in,
in Moy Tai,
there's so much distance involved in so many other techniques and so many,
so many options and possibilities that are really technical fighter.
You know,
like Amir said,
dolla good example,
right.
And mirsa dolls,
a real technical guy,
but not a physically strong guy by any stretch of the imagination.
Not a super athlete,
just a regular guy but became pretty technical with is more time,
you know,
for sure.
And he could beat guys who are a lot faster and stronger.
Yeah,
he had definitely a good base.
And then retire for sure.
I wanted to talk to you about your system because you're the,
like as far as the people that I know that I've really spent the most time
trying to break things down into,
I know the Dutch do it a lot and uh,
I had the pleasure of training with rob came in several times and he's a very
good guy and he has a whole system that he teaches,
you know,
he's got this Cayman Moitai system cool that he,
uh,
is,
he's basically in a lot of ways like you as kind of sort of broken down all the
various possibilities that can happen in a fight.
But I think you've done a another level.
You've taken it to even wackier place where you just,
you know,
you're
thinking about it all.
God Damn Day came in part,
doesn't even know his own Combo and [inaudible] test system.
We have a comma that's named after him.
He doesn't even know it.
Is it a round kick across the front of the size and helps.
He loves that technique,
man.
He would throw that that round kick across the front of the thighs of both legs
all the time.
And that's a beautiful technique.
He liked to some of the fights that I've seen,
he would pick the front kick and come down to the hook off that same time that
came in to come down at the same side Hook.
Yeah.
That was another technique is he would just crappy,
hard hook,
solid hug for sure.
I love,
oh sorry.
I was just going to say I love watching old rob came and fucked.
Yes.
I bought his uh,
his VHS,
VHS instruction and I aced it and just take notes on those and watch those all
day long.
Like I just obsessed about that stuff and my style is based more off the judge
stop because it's coming up to Boston route and stuff.
You guys haven't figured out if,
sorry,
I can't even hear myself.
No one's figured out.
If you want to be a really good coach,
you have to be a psychopath to Oh,
you have to be,
you have to be a little twisted to get what he's figuring out inside the head.
And he's always got something going on then.
Well,
you have to be twisted to be a competitor to you or you come off.
You're an interesting guy because you come off like the sweetest,
kindest guy in the world,
but however I hear training with you is not,
not not a an ice cream Sundae.
I guys pick your partners.
Who's working with Tj?
Hey,
did you sign the liability waiver?
Yeah.
Okay,
cool.
We're good.
Start around.
I'm always the last one to get a partner.
No one wants to play with me.
Do you think that,
I mean is it because you're so amped up and competitive and you only turn it on
in competition and when you're in there you're just in there to go to war.
You're not in there to make nice,
nice.
You just seem to go to war and that's the only way to get better.
I'm super
nice guy.
He loves it.
He used to watch,
I can watch UFC fights all day long.
He controls me like he's been,
we've been trying to get this controlled aggression that I have is I'm very
aggressive when I'm competing because I'm really competitive and I want to be
the best in the world.
So I'm practice.
I want to practice the best to be the best.
And when things don't work out exactly the way it's supposed to,
I get pissed and go harder and it's something he's had to control with me.
You know,
I've,
I've learned to control my aggression and turn on at the right times,
but it's taken a long time to do that.
So everyone's got this name for me as being,
you know,
the bully and the gym cause it goes hard.
He definitely goes hard,
but he's got what can't be taught.
So I just got to be controlled as all.
Yeah.
It's simply a matter of how much damage you,
you take this unnecessary or give out that's unnecessary in the training.
But other than that,
to have that mad intensity,
that is what it takes.
There's only one way to be a champion.
You can't be a champion and kind of,
well you know,
I'll give it my best.
You can't.
Nope.
The doctorate,
there's other dudes out there like Tj Dillashaw.
That's just the way it is.
Like that's what I would tell people whenever anyone talks about dabbling in
fighting,
you know,
they,
they say,
hey,
why don't you have an MMA fight?
You know,
they,
you know,
we should have an MMA fight,
that guy,
but he can kick some ass listened to me and less.
That's what you're obsessed with.
Unless that is occupying your thoughts 24 hours a day.
And when people start talking to you,
if you don't like what they're saying,
you start thinking about fighting unless that's going on,
don't fight because there's someone out there like Tj Dillashaw this,
these motherfuckers out there that are like that all day long and they will get
in the same cage as you and light you on fire and there's not a goddamn thing
you can do about it.
That's true.
That's some people's journey and they just want to go through the process of a
fight camp,
physical fight,
just to experience it.
That's until I guess,
fuck,
relax.
So maybe if they get the right match up or somebody who is equally as skilled or
just for they have the event,
then it's fine.
But yeah,
definitely.
You don't want to come across someone like to date another shot.
He's a world class athlete that's dedicated and that will kill you.
Yeah,
and you could have run into a gallery out in the amateurs.
You can easily run into,
yeah,
I had two amateur fights.
Yeah.
I was obviously not as mature.
Yeah,
you weren't as good,
but still you could run into some,
especially due to that freaky power guys would have that Lavard Johnson type
power.
You could run into those dudes and you're going to check,
your head's going to be fucked up for a long time just because you wanted an
adventure.
Yeah.
Be careful.
He's got to research your opponent.
You got to.
You should be.
I think martial arts are a great thing to be involved with.
If you're going to fight in MMA,
you better be goddamn obsessed.
Yeah.
That's why I think this combination of youtube is so fascinating to me because
you're both bananas.
You're both upset like there should be some scientific studies going on,
man.
Yeah.
Maybe there's some data that can be pulled from the early fights and the
coaching videos and stuff like that up until now because I'm curious to see all
the improvements involvements that just the improvements of every aspect of the
game.
Well,
there's so many improvements behind the scenes and a lot of folks don't know
about like how to train what like there's all these like different thoughts and
strategies about fa training it out to two or sleeping it out suit and training.
Now it's now that's what they say.
Train at sea level,
sleep at altitude and that has a pretty significant impact and then your diet.
If guys are like,
oh,
let's get out the gluten.
Okay,
we're going to do today we're going to do Tabata training protocols.
What do you think about gluten?
I think that it's not the best thing for your body.
It's fucking glue or you're taking your breaking wheat down.
It's turning it into let's just chew,
like when you eat bread,
chew that shit up and feel what it feels like.
It's glue and glue.
I've never really looked into it as much because I'm able to eat.
Like I eat healthy and I eat really healthy.
It just for the Diet makes me feel good and Google's never has ever bothered me
before.
And Danny Castillo has gotten as gluten free diet and he's like really strict
about it.
I always make fun of him and I,
you know how he's going to ship.
I would go somewhere he can't eat anything.
He was like,
come on man,
I'll pay extra for that gluten.
Give me extra gluten and then I'll eat it,
you know?
But uh,
I don't think it's bad for you.
I've tried gluten free.
I was gluten free for a long time and then I allow myself to eat at once a week,
which they say you're not supposed to do if you're really gluten free is
supposed to be gluten free 100% but what I think is,
it's like a lot of things,
it's like beer.
It's like bread,
the the,
it's like cake.
It's not good for you,
but I like it anyway.
I got like a little bit of it.
I think you should for the most part,
taking things that are really good for you.
But I think gluten isn't,
it's just,
it causes inflammation and it's difficult to digest just a little bit,
not a lot.
And for some people it's a lot.
Some people have like CELIAC's disease and check the,
for those people it's pretty significant.
You feel worse when you have that day of like the next day.
Do you feel worse?
I feel like a fat fuck.
Yeah.
Feel,
feel like watered down.
I feel like raw.
Like when Ali Ead,
um,
uh,
I'll,
I'll eat a sandwich or something like that,
like a meatball sub or something fucking stupid on my cheat day.
And that bond soaked up with spaghetti sauce,
just sits in my stomach like a rock face.
So good though.
So good.
When it's going down for a few moments of simple Mt.
Pleasure.
I'll allow myself like shit for 24 hours.
You feel it when you work out too.
That's when I feel it,
it takes a longer time to digest for me.
If I eat like just standard protein,
you know,
like fish and vegetables.
It doesn't take me long to digest a nice plate of a healthy fish and uh,
some,
some Greens like Kale or you know,
uh,
any ruble or some shit like that,
that's like two,
three hours later I feel great I can work out.
But if I eat like a pizza,
I'm fucked for a while.
Yup.
I'm fucked for five or six hours.
It's not gonna be any working out pizza.
And now that I eat healthy,
I can fill the huge difference that you eaten bad.
But it's because I've gotten into the profession of what I do,
gives me money and since I've been blending all my fruit and vegetables,
it's insane how much I can eat vegetable wise.
Like if I blend it up in the BLENDTEC I got like,
it's like I eight times as much fruit and vegetables.
I used to when I was wrestling just because I make a blend once a day.
That's so awesome.
It's so good for you.
As long as you mix it up.
Um,
I've been reading about people that,
that do run into issues if they eat all of their meals as blended vegetables.
He used to like if you get a certain amount of oxalic acid and a bunch of
different things that exist in um,
in plants too.
I probably did discourage animals from eating them.
But if you have been massive doses like that,
like over and over again,
like spinach,
apparently raw spinach,
very high in oxalic acid,
but as long as you mix it up it's fine.
And as long as you have calcium in your diet,
calcium in your diet sends to mitigate it in some way.
But there's no,
there's no better way.
It's like you're getting like mainline and nutrients.
I drink one of those cal shakes dude.
And I feel like I did fucking like two shots of espresso,
fire it up in the morning.
Every morning when I'm at home,
I have,
I have a green shake for the morning also and blend that puppy up and just chomp
it down back to honor it.
If you want it to taste good,
you just got to put the hemp force in advance.
Everything blend up dog shit.
And he was like,
seriously?
That's the Stevia,
the what we use for sweetness.
So this shit the same stuff that I use on my,
uh,
you thought it was salt?
Yeah.
The same stuff that I use in my,
um,
my coffee.
It's a natural plant.
Extract,
no sugar in it at all and you just need a tiny little bit.
It's super potent,
like 10 times more potent than sugar.
Definitely.
Um,
but yeah man,
when
I,
when I used to make it taste good,
but now I don't even make the Kale shake.
Tastes good anymore.
Now I'm making it,
I make it taste terrible cause I give a giant chunks of ginger and garlic now
like I'll have like a series,
like remember what pages you still look like page,
last chunk of ginger.
Just fucking hammer it.
Ooh,
that's in one shake.
You slammed that,
that Messenger.
Oh fuck.
I'm like that turtle was have about half of that in a week shake.
Oh really?
Yeah.
No,
I slam it.
Slam it and four or five cloves of garlic to hitting a house.
No.
So bad afterwards.
Smelling like garlic can take for sure.
Well good look a yoke man.
I smelled like shit.
Like garlic.
No,
just uh,
just ate some garlic.
Your loads.
Yeah.
It's become horrible.
I don't know.
Why don't you try it.
Let me know next time you were in,
say Stevie on it.
You'll be all right.
Thanks.
Take me to take tests and mood to make a video.
It's probably get a lot of youtube bits piss off of that.
Yeah.
If you just all you'd have to do,
it's just I would come on the desk and just dip your finger and go like that.
That's all you would have to do.
And G,
P and g,
it's over.
Youtube would break.
I'm sure you've got the curdled kind where you could just pick it up.
No,
my loads are very normal,
fertile time.
This shit took a lot of water,
dude.
Oh,
that's true.
Healthy.
My loads of quite fluid taste like garlic and this is like back at the,
at the academy right here.
Imagine if we do,
we're like checks,
whereas women have a certain amount of eggs and then that's it.
It's over.
Imagine if dudes were like that.
We have a certain amount of loads,
you know,
you like checking,
you look uphold your balls up to the sun to see like where your load line was.
A lot of people would have wasted,
a lot of people would have blue balls,
that's for sure.
Saved my lows.
Be like next day.
Oh Wow.
Girls will be like,
come on gimme some low.
You're not worth it.
You're not worth it to like a gambling.
Rational guys would go and they'd go,
tantric,
we squeeze it down to never really orgasm.
If that was the tip of your Dick,
like a lighter.
And if that was the case,
if that was the case,
guys,
you'd have more power and getting laid there on the girls side of it,
you know,
like it's easy,
easier for a girl.
It'd be a whole lot easier for a guy if you only had so many of us and if we all
fucking band together,
we can make that happen.
Just start this right now.
If the fuck guys,
puck as as powerful,
have a Dick Union,
take back your loads.
Your loads are important.
They're not valued right now in the equation,
but damn it,
they should be.
Stop wasting them.
It's a key ingredient in making people,
oh man.
Without the loads,
you got nothing.
That's the problem though is like that would be like starting a fighters' union.
Like that's not really gonna Happen,
you know?
But this dude's like fuck down.
That's what dudes would say when it comes to the Dick Union.
If we all got together and said,
listen,
we're gonna,
we're gonna.
We need to make our dicks more valuable.
Okay.
When we need to make it harder to get to what's worked.
Something out here boys,
the first ones are going to sacrifice big time,
man.
The ones that are starting this thing.
Cause now that they're the only ones not getting laid to start this whole trend,
you know,
same as with the fighter union.
You only one not getting paid.
Right.
They would be the ones who would step in and say,
you know,
equal pay for equal fighting or something.
Oh,
people have in the past.
I'm sure it's very difficult.
My point would be this like,
it's like even comedians unions is now going to kill me.
I mean,
I guess the condom maybe has been sort of,
I think there's something like that.
There's some sort of a union that they tried to put together.
Tj Dillashaw drinks a lot of water.
He's a healthy boy.
How do you know Mike Epps is,
by the way,
did you read that he beat up that other comedians can beat up a comedian for a
joke that's hilarious.
Stole the joke.
No,
the guy did a joke on his Instagram where he's,
he snorted coke and uh,
he pretended he was Mike Epps.
He did like a mic apps joke and then,
um,
uh,
Mike apps and his boys beat the fuck out of him.
I guess he was mocking the Kevin Hart field.
Yeah.
Yeah,
because Kevin Hart and Mike Apps were in some sort of a beef,
uh,
Mike,
Mike capps just talking shit about Kevin Hart and Kevin Hart made a video about
it and said,
you know,
you're not on my level and you need to up your ticket sales.
Hilarious.
Kevin Hart's hilarious.
Uh,
I don't know who was,
you know what started it all?
I have no idea.
But apparently Mike apps didn't like what this guy did on his Instagram.
Have you seen the video?
He did.
No,
it's available.
You can get it.
Pull it,
pull it up.
It's off of his Instagram on the guy that got beat up.
Yeah.
He,
um,
he did a video where you pretend to be microbes with coke all over his nose.
And then he,
he did a Kevin Hart impression where he's on his knees.
I mean,
it's not the best peace in the world.
It's totally some people off,
Huh?
Did he take it down?
People are being sensitive.
Is that,
where is it?
It's not that far away.
This is May.
Uh,
well just try to find the video,
like do a search on it because it's a,
it'll pop up really quickly.
Yeah,
it's fucked up man.
Comedians hitting each other with jokes.
That's the most ridiculous thing ever.
Especially if it's you.
If it's a guy who does coke,
if you do,
you do coke bitch.
No Sir.
How can I mean?
I'm saying not you.
I mean if you do,
you can't be mad if someone makes fun of you doing coke.
You know,
like if someone did a video with me smoking weed,
what,
what am I going to say?
That's how region.
Who are you?
What kind of fucking bullshit is this?
I was afraid and come back from the bathroom.
Everyone was getting beat up by doing Keven come to controlling,
go to the bathroom.
I was,
I got to make this quick cause the going to get pissed and they're like leaving
Starbucks and you're like,
shit,
let everything be okay.
Some funny,
funny stories about Duane.
Like when I first started hanging out with him to go on UFC trips,
you know,
and he's always on watch what people are talking about and just kind of like,
kind of got this,
this stand like someone's always talking shit kind of deal.
You know this,
this guys just started working for the UFC and he's given us a ride to the
grocery store to pick up our healthy stuff for the week and to keep it in our
room and Dwayne's talking,
he's telling a story and this guy interrupts him a couple times,
you know?
And I can see Dwayne get pissed about it.
And like I just,
I only know Dwayne now for like a month,
maybe two.
And he's out my first fight and like I'm nervous,
you know,
cause like he yeah it comes across really harsh to people.
But if you understand his personality,
he's joking,
but it's hard to tell if he's joking cause we keep setting up this guy,
he's like,
you don't want me one more time.
I would drop you.
Oh,
you know,
he asked us,
hey,
if you guys keep being rude,
I'll drop you off here in the corner.
He's like,
if you keep being real,
drop you right now in this car.
And the guy shut off for the entire ride.
Like he was like so scared.
Like,
man,
we're cool now.
But he was
scared while we were in the car as it was definitely scared.
Yeah.
I'm never really going to beat somebody up on the,
I don't find a long time,
but I'm a,
I'm dead serious about as far as like interrupting that someone I finished
there,
you know,
it's like a Marshall.
It's like a,
it's like a martial arts respect.
That's right.
Yeah.
People do it accidentally.
There's a lot of folks that don't do it around.
Well,
some guys are not that skilled in the art of,
of talking,
you know,
there's this weird,
uh,
little,
moments where you want to say something and he can't and you're like,
Eh,
you know,
great.
Great.
Okay.
Ready yet?
But his manager,
it was Mike as Mike.
Jeff is Jeff.
It was Jeff.
And,
uh,
I was talking to somebody,
I was like,
well,
Danny or somebody and it comes up in the interrupted,
right.
And it was like,
keep interrupting him,
motherfucker.
Like I'm not seriously mad,
but like,
but seriously let me finish then,
you know,
say your shit.
Right.
But anyway,
he got,
I guess,
you know,
he thought I was serious.
Like he went and told one of the guys,
Ms 20,
just a serious asshole or what I heard about like secondary,
like,
Oh man,
I'm sorry.
I was just fucking around.
So I definitely come across a bit.
It's been around,
but you're also letting people know that.
Yeah,
yeah,
for sure.
Usually people do it politely and it's like,
hey man,
hold on a second.
I got something to say like,
Hey motherfucker do you should I can interrupt me again.
I'm gonna fuck you up.
Yeah,
I know.
Let me finish my story.
There's some people that are so bad at it,
you can't even have a conversation socially awkward.
And should I just go there?
Was this your,
we're never going to really be talking.
I'm just waiting for you to finish.
This is a crazy conversation.
I,
they sometimes to my answers,
I'll just fucking go off on a tangent.
I forgot what I'm talking about.
I actually,
I'd be like quite a bit.
Sorry.
Go ahead.
Well that's good though,
man.
That's where creativity lies.
Stuck in a predictable pattern.
Yup.
Tangents are where the,
the wild ideas come from,
from holding your balls up to the sun.
See where you're at.
How many loads are left,
where's that coming from?
The universe.
It's just the video.
Brian's TMZ talking.
Oh,
we don't need a play that stop.
Stop,
stop,
stop.
Stop.
That's going to get us kicked off of Youtube.
But no,
no.
Hold on.
We can't,
we keep getting pulled off youtube.
It's happened three times this month.
Right.
So like anytime there's a youtube clip from now on,
I'm not playing them anymore.
I mean,
unless it's something that you're like,
these guys are not going to like put a,
you know,
it's their video.
They come in,
we get pulled from youtube like every week.
It's crazy.
Wow.
Hmm.
Every time we play a youtube clip,
either somebody wants money for,
there's some,
you know,
some of you who don't know what the deal is,
it's not them.
It's people make claims against your video.
Oh,
even TMZ though.
I don't know.
I don't know if they're gonna.
I mean it seems like everybody's doing it.
I mean,
we did it last year was like last week was guy named nature documentary video,
some snake kill and a crocodile.
We got pulled off of Youtube.
Oh Wow.
It's ridiculous.
We're getting told off constantly for these little youtube videos.
So just play that dude's video off of Instagram.
Yeah,
I think it got taken off of Instagram,
but it's a up somewhere else.
Oh really?
Huh?
That's interesting.
Or it is.
We've got took down.
Huh?
So this dude made fun of Mike Epps and Mike Epps and his buddies would beat the
shit out of him.
So that's what's going on today.
Yeah.
Mike Epps beat up a comedian for telling a joke about them.
Can't be telling jokes sometimes.
Here it is right here.
Oh look,
good government checkup or near here.
But yeah,
Kevin,
I said you was overrated Nigga.
Okay.
His deal flow,
you get on me.
Did you get the sales up Pam?
That's it.
And beat the dude up for that.
Really?
Yup.
Wow.
I mean,
I don't know.
I mean maybe confronted him and then the dude was like,
fuck you Mike Epps.
And the due to swinging him there,
he knows.
And then my caps beat him up.
I don't know what really didn't know Mike Epps?
Nope.
I don't know.
Is He,
is he should laugh factory guy or is it,
I don't know.
I have no idea.
I mean,
I've seen his name up there maybe in the past.
Quite honestly.
I don't know the dude.
Yeah,
I dunno.
But um,
I don't know the dude in Atlanta either who got beat up,
but it's just ridiculous.
If you do coke and somebody hits you or somebody makes a joke about you,
like you can't hit him.
Right.
If that's ridiculous.
You're aren't you a comedian?
Yeah.
I mean,
make fun of people all the time.
Yeah.
What if it's funny,
if someone makes fun of you and it's actually funny,
you should be laughing stupid.
You just think that was funny though.
Is that a funny video?
It depends on if he does coke and I don't have a story behind it.
If he does coke,
yeah,
it makes it funnier.
But I'm sure if he doesn't do cocaine,
yeah.
If he's like me,
he's never done coke in his life and he sees a fee like I've been called a
cokehead before,
like so why don't you give him more coked up and drew the UFC?
Like I always hear that you're do you do in the UFC it's just,
it's called have an energy gone based passion.
Passionate human being on the phone.
You're not a robot.
So maybe if he's never done coke and he saw that he would go,
this is bullshit.
I don't even do come.
And they would get mad at the dude.
Yeah.
But if he does do coke,
you've got to let that slide.
Like you said,
like why get mad about something?
Someone's make it funny.
If it is funny,
just laugh about it.
But that's why jokes have about people because they get like,
like me,
like Danny tries making fun of me and I'll just go,
I'll go along with it.
I'll laugh like whatever.
You know.
So I don't get to the brunt end of it too much of like Holdsworth he like takes
offense to it.
You know,
he gets pissed at Danny just eats him apart.
You know?
Like if you,
if you continue to get mad about the joke,
it's funny.
We're going to keep doing it.
You know,
Christine,
it was fun.
We got to get him on the podcast.
Oh yeah.
Without a doubt.
Next time.
Yeah.
Next time you guys come down this way,
Danny bring him by.
Hell.
He's a funny dude.
I liked hanging out with him in Austin.
That was the only time I really hung out with you guys before it really got to
sit down and talk to you guys.
Austin,
besides doing the podcast.
But Danny,
I'd never before just leaving them out fights,
you know?
Yeah.
We'd have to have gone through the whole,
the whole team and fucking awesome crew it let's do it.
Yeah,
for sure.
We started our own a tam radio,
a little podcast deal,
you know,
kind of messing around.
We've
got Bruce buffer that announced that shit.
We should do that too.
He would for sure.
He loves us.
Do you see him announcing Michael Bisbing at his wedding?
Oh,
that's cool.
Yeah,
it was pretty cool.
but we started with like two years ago when I was ultimate fighter.
I break down each episode and it was a pretty cool little thing we started.
We had,
I mean it wasn't anything big,
but we got some normal followers and then Uriah shut it down because he wanted
to start his own Sirius radio show.
He was going to be your eyes block party,
so you may just stop doing it.
And then his radio show never happened.
And so now two years later,
we did our first one again after my fight and it was the most disorganized
Travis like Jv Jv of podcasts,
you know,
so I need to talk to your wife favor.
You can't think like that.
Yeah.
That's the incorrect way of thinking.
I hate to say that,
but what you should do is if a guy does a podcast,
then you do one,
two and then both your podcast feed off of each other and you promote each
other.
Yeah,
exactly.
There's plenty of room for other podcasts,
but there's room for a thousand of them and he just considered team Alpha male
has his team,
so he said we're using Tam.
Radio reasons team not familiar.
Yeah.
For him it's only going to benefit his branch here and you guys are a part of
team Alpha male.
You said,
hey team Alpha Male,
you represented in the cage.
You give a percentage of your,
your purse to that.
I mean that's like being from Yale and not being able to say you're from Yale.
I mean we're the Yale lawyers.
Did you know you're not allowed to say that.
What the fuck are you talking about?
Okay,
I'm in Yale and I'm a lawyer,
you know,
or whatever.
You know what I'm saying?
I mean it just seems like it would only benefit him to have you guys doing that
for sure.
And it would put more attention on the team too,
That's why we started it up again.
We're going to try to try to make it run out and see how it goes.
I don't know.
We got some funny guys on the team,
so you're why you should do a serious one if he wants to do a serious one.
But there's nothing wrong with you guys doing one with fucking Joe Benevidez
showing his nipple rings be ridiculous.
Dwayne is like,
he doesn't like the [inaudible] wrestlers.
So wrestlers were all flexible.
Wrestlers are freaks,
right?
So he comes to our team and we're a whole team of freaks.
Like,
no,
you know,
joking around.
Yeah,
exactly.
A little bit too close,
living too close to each other then he should be.
He's like,
man,
I stopped this knock,
knock this stuff off.
He's like completely anti like what?
Whatever we're doing,
you know,
and it makes them uncomfortable.
Wrestles a kiss you on the mouth just to freak you out.
It's just a free
tried to get gift to kiss Joseph on the way into the cage because,
uh,
um,
Frig Mirrors,
dad always kisses him before he goes in the cage.
She'll like,
come on,
give him a mouth.
You got to get through the course,
a kiss on the mouth when we're going into the cage before we fight.
So it was,
we got to make out a little bit,
you know,
the gift was like,
you kidding me?
Like he thought we were serious and you know,
awesome man,
he's coming up right.
Cause we cope and go for a couple days.
It's a weird thing about wrestlers is,
uh,
you know,
this,
the attitude and the,
the,
the intensity that is developed in wrestling rooms is,
it's not like anything else.
The amount of hard work that you have to do to be a successful amateur wrestler
is really,
is incredible.
So the amount of stress that's involved with being a wrestler is also pretty
nutty.
And then the amount of one upsmanship because you're around a bunch of fucking
savages and every savage wants to be known as the sick fuck.
You know,
like there's like,
you know,
I thought it was a sick fuck until I started training with Frank Frank Shit in
some guy's lunch pail.
You know,
there's always something and it's,
a lot of it is like pushing each other and feeding off of each cal state
Fullerton.
I wrestled the locker room antics were ridiculous,
let alone like I'm telling you,
it's crazy stuff and everyone's one upping each other.
Not only in the gym but you're in the locker rooms as well,
you know.
But there's always one dude.
It takes a 2.24 yeah,
I'm on.
Would that be at the academy?
At our academy or when I was wrestling?
No,
I dunno.
Maybe Danny kissed he,
yeah,
he takes it too far,
man.
He does.
He makes people all of I'm about to cry.
He's good man.
I've seen him and Justin Buckles Hirsi ruin someone's career.
I think.
Man,
we had this boxer that came into our gym or take it awesome boxer like awesome.
And he got so good at him and so fast was doing awesome.
Double legs.
Jiu Jitsu was catching on quick.
He was like a thug though.
He grew up on the streets and uh,
you know,
we,
everyone respected him.
We got in the gym and he's beaten Danny up like Danny's in the UFC and we're
take as,
you know,
getting the best of him in the gym,
and then we go on this trip down to southern California to go train and we hang
out with or take ticket for like five days straight and we find out who he is
and you know how like,
I don't know,
he's just mentally weak kind of,
you know.
And so they started making fun of him,
breaking them down and they broke them down so hard for five days straight.
Then when we got back to the gym,
like everything fell apart for him.
His dog died,
got bit by a rattlesnake.
He crashed and totaled his car and then like just started losing fights.
And Dan,
ever since Auntie found out how like mentally weak he wasn't how he could take
advantage of him.
He started just kicking his butt in the gym mentally,
Blah.
I broke it down,
mentally broke him down.
I was like,
Danny,
that's messed up.
Did you use ruin that guy?
He's like,
I know.
I feel bad.
He feels bad.
Oh yeah.
I mean,
yeah,
this kid was awesome.
Do you ever take it was the man,
he was crazy.
It was looking good in the gym and then just got broke down.
How that is really bizarre.
That's a fascinating psychological study.
Yeah.
I mean I hate the dude had to suffer to get that data,
but it is quite interesting.
Like Danny respected him so much when we were practicing.
He was getting beat up by him,
but then once he found out who he was,
I mean or take is awesome.
But once he found out that he was just some other kid that was easily made fun
of it,
took it,
took it to heart,
then he just broke him and beat him up in the gym too.
Wow.
That's really weird.
But it's that kind of shit like people would say that's cruel.
That's horrible.
That's it.
But the mental game is just as important as the physical.
If not someone,
you're kind of doing mental sparring when you're around a bunch of savages.
Yep.
You know,
you really are.
I mean,
I used to remember snide comments that guys would say right before you would
spar like dude's weird shit to you.
You're like,
what is going on?
I got a negative weird shit is it?
And they're planting seeds of doubt in your head.
You know,
man,
that's what,
you know,
we don't have any of that.
The academy,
the whole,
the team here,
man.
It's a really a special time.
Like a bad ass up that or tag a fellow.
Ask him about that.
But I guess recently I saw him there.
We saved his life though,
man.
Like we've turned them into like so much of a better person.
He's got his own jam,
he's getting married,
he's having a kid like his gym successful.
Like he's on the right path.
Like things happen the right way for him.
Like he's successful now,
you know,
and he's a great boxer still to this day.
But I think,
I mean,
he was good,
but I don't think he could have made it to the elite level to make a living off
of fighting,
you know?
So you kind of fast track the,
the,
I think the failure of it,
you know?
That's interesting.
Yeah.
Or maybe he would've had a rise from the fire,
you know,
figure it out and get his mental game.
The same area where it's physical game was,
some guys can do that,
you know,
you can't,
you make gains in both areas for sure.
Yeah.
But it's harder,
it seems like to make gains in the mental area.
Yeah,
I think so.
Physical is obviously very difficult as well,
but there's something about what a guy loses his confidence.
Very difficult to get that confidence back.
That's one thing too.
It's called the,
all these guys here at the Academy at two Ma Famille.
They're all super mentally tough because you know there are winners and
wrestling and that just brought on through and now they like sickening work
ethic with the proper technique down,
have lunch,
just helping each other out is,
it's a,
it's a mastermind group of martial arts.
It's,
it,
it's,
we're,
we're involved in the current stage of the martial art evolution right now
without a doubt.
And wrestling so tough that it makes fighting for me so much easier.
Like the,
the,
the struggles I had through wrestling and how hard it was on me,
hard,
it was on my body and we compete for,
you know,
six to nine months straight.
Like you're in the gym grinding for that long straight and then you have this
break to whereas fighting,
you get to peak yourself,
fight for each event,
you know,
but wrestling your restaurant every week and you're grinding and all throughout
a whole season.
And then you get to the end of the year and stay at top form.
You know,
so many people get hurt and it affects the way that the NCAAs go down.
I mean I feel,
I feel like the smarter coaches don't have the guys go as hard in the beginning
of the season and then picked him for the end,
which they should do,
you know.
And uh,
I wish I would've known that more.
Like I know now that I'm a professional athlete,
I wish I would've known how to peak myself for wrestling like I do for fighting.
Do you have a guy who works at you the way Duane Doug's was striking with your,
your conditioning and monitoring your heart rate and um,
I'm,
I'm slowly getting into that.
I've,
I've had to go back and forth where I'm training for my strength,
my strength conditioning.
I found a new guy from,
for this first camp or the first time I've used him
for this camp for a brow.
And,
uh,
I wanted to put some size on,
you know,
and so I do a lot of strengthening for when I was far out and,
um,
cause I knew brown was a big guy.
I don't want to be able to use my muscle against his.
Um,
but yeah,
I would still want to get more into that.
I feel,
I feel training outside the gym is really important to stay in healthy instead
of just grinding,
beating herself up every day with the martial arts into it.
You know,
you see GSP doing all this stuff to keep his body healthy and strong and I feel
like that will prolong my career if I can do that.
Yeah.
Strength training especially it seems to,
uh,
protect a lot of guys from a certain amount of injuries.
But then again,
it causes a certain amount of injuries.
You know,
there's a lot of guys get injured from strength and conditioning work and then
they're broken down by the time they get into the gym,
doing it wrong.
Cynthia,
it's hard.
And doing drills.
See,
I need to,
I need to find a coach that knows MMA as well because I don't think like a lot
of strength conditioning coaches don't realize how hard you're working every
day.
You know,
I'll go into the gym and I have two hard practices and then I end my day with
strength conditioning because you know,
I don't want to hinder my performance in the gym.
So I wanted to make my strength conditioning last and then he's trying to make
kill me in that workout too.
So it's like,
man,
I'm doing three workouts that are ridiculously hard.
Maybe on this day we should go lighter,
you know,
are are siloed off my training schedule and know more about the sport and this
Guy Ish I've been trained with it does a really good job of,
it almost goes to hard,
but I've kind of had to help him pick me.
Yeah,
that's good about communication with a good coach to make sure you're pushed him
just enough to put them back if need be.
That's one thing to hear at the time.
Familiar I have,
I have a coach's dream.
These guys work hard.
The only thing I need to do is pull them back at,
they have no problem going hard and it's,
there's no babysitting in my job at all.
That's so fantastic.
That's the biggest complaint you ever hear about trainers.
Nobody's having to babysit a talented fighter that doesn't like to train.
You always heard that about,
you know,
I hate to bring up his name rampage.
You know we started,
that was a great fight when grant page was on.
I mean people talk a lot of shit about rampers I'd never talked shit about
rampage cause he's all,
especially the pride days,
that dude earned his status for life.
That slam of Ricardo Arona oh he's locked up in that triangle.
Knocked out Kevin Randleman.
That's right dude.
The rampage from the pride days.
You know that guy just,
just for that.
Forget about knocking out chocolate.
Dell.
Forget about any fights just from that.
But you know rampage like it's a job and he gets paid a lot of money to do it.
But I don't necessarily know how motivated he is at certain fights.
I'm like,
and he's hot.
Dolce had a problem with it and other guys about a problem with it,
but he's so fucking talented.
Yeah.
You get a guy like him get a brain and the kind of motivation of of you know a
younger rampage.
That's where a perfect example right here,
world class athlete with the proper information,
good training partners and world champion.
Like this is the thing cutting edge martial art right here.
He moved me.
There's nothing better than this who being right now as far as the martial arts
ever.
It's crazy.
It's,
it is,
but don't tell him that.
Right?
It's too late.
Just did I start getting better?
Getting better for sure.
Yeah.
We've got prime yet adding new things been awesome for me to live
to these guys.
It's,
it's crazy is the way you said you spun out of his turning sidekick to every
time he threw that turning psychic,
you used his body like on the turn you would like with him the entire way.
It's like you were just a half a step ahead of his movement all the way around
the curve.
It's amazing.
I know.
I seriously had so much fun in there.
Like I mean it's,
it's,
it's a nerve wracking thing you're doing right.
You're getting into a cage to fight in the pound for pound the best guy?
Well,
I mean let alone any guy get in the cage with your nervous obviously just to
perform.
But uh,
I had so much fun that I soaked it all up and just kind of,
I don't know what the fight was in slow motion for me.
I mean I felt like,
I felt like the fight was almost an hour long and I could've let it go.
I feel like I would've gone even though obviously I want that belt around my
waist and want to be done as soon as possible.
I felt like I could have gone so much longer just because I was,
I was in the zone to where like it's professional athletes would pay so much
money to get obviously,
you know,
it just,
uh,
it felt amazing in every time he threw spin kick.
I just saw it and he's got a fast one,
but I would just see what you see.
There it is right here.
Look,
you can see it right here and see.
I actually could have taken his back a couple of times when he threw those pink
kicks.
And I just,
I don't,
for some reason I just kept striking.
It's just,
I don't know.
I'm almost natural.
Yeah.
That's the article that I was bringing up.
It's on fight land,
which is a,
a vice,
oh,
those guys are awesome.
And it is,
the Dude's name is Jack Slack and says how Dell,
how t J.
Dot.
Killed the king.
I did see this.
It's a great article.
It's really good.
As far as like the technical aspects of striking broke it down very well in a
way that it's,
it's,
it's really difficult to break down and very difficult to do.
So,
especially if you're a like trying to do it,
doing commentary because there's a lot of aspects of movement that he's taking
into account about loading up and about firing one,
two shots at a time,
being predictable and now other guys are kind of exposed it.
He showed,
um,
uh,
his,
his fight with Eddie Wineland.
Yeah.
Wineland made him move a lot when he frightened with it,
uh,
at bear air.
And also with Brad Pickett a little bit.
He showed some of that as well as his brawling.
Yeah.
So this,
this actually came out before my fight.
Obviously the new stuff with me up there is new.
Oh,
this came out after your fight.
There's the images.
Oh,
this tea?
No,
this is how you killed the king.
Yeah.
Those are,
there was an article just like this,
I think it might've been from the same person.
Yes.
It was broke down.
The broke down exactly how to beat Burrell is before my fight.
And he was like going over things that how like obviously browse in awesome
champion,
but these are little holes that you can maybe figure out on him.
And it came up before my fight and buckles had me watching it in my room week to
become my fight.
And it was funny because the guy,
whoever did it was really good because,
uh,
he,
he really,
we're,
we're already doing all this stuff he was talking about like,
it went hand in hand with when me and Dwayne roadie practicing and uh,
yeah,
yeah.
That's another article called killing the king.
Yes.
You know,
and it's amazing because this guy gave you some advice.
Great Advice.
It was good.
It was good stuff.
Yeah.
And it does show the killing the king.
Um,
one
is a equally interesting and a equally well informed.
He's excellent.
Very,
very good writer.
But that's another example of what I was talking about at this new breed of a,
of rider and fan that's coming along.
These people that have been involved,
if don't show him,
lose it.
He's got a shrink my head a little bit.
Yeah.
I've got to fit through the door.
If this is the wrong shit to show the show.
I was just scrolling it.
Yeah.
And you paused on it for a long time looking to see what happened to it.
It looked like you injured your leg up.
We can show you if you want.
Now those,
the vice fight land was by far my,
I think my favorite interviews I did leading up to the fight.
Like I did a big PR tour and I went and talked with Dan and then they were there
like the day before my fight or two days before my fight.
I think those are my favorite interviews to do.
They were,
they were cool dudes.
Yeah.
The vice guys will,
Shane Smith is a friend of ours and he's a,
you know,
the founder of the whole thing and it all trickles down from him.
He's an interesting cat.
Very,
very nice guy too.
It's been on podcast three times,
right?
Yeah.
And he's a huge,
huge fan of the UFC and just a guy who was just experienced almost too much,
you know,
he's almost been around to too many different places.
It's been too many different parts of the world.
He's like,
he gets overwhelmed sometimes,
just talk to him.
He starts talking about the nuclear conflict with Pakistan and India and fucking
Manhattan's going under water.
And I mean he's just traveling all over the world.
The fucked up.
So we went Chernobyl,
nuclear wolves with rifles like,
so all this talk is negative for the most part.
A,
well,
not necessarily.
He's a really friendly,
sweet guy,
but I think maybe he sees a little too much.
I gotcha.
Yeah.
You're going to be a product of your environment.
Just like a fighter.
It's not supposed to spar three times a day every day.
You're probably not supposed to skip crazy.
He came into her life and changed it up cause that's what we used to do.
Did you really change that three times a day?
We train like weed spot it like three times a week I think sometimes.
Not always,
but before he got there we did a lot more sparring.
You know,
which looking back I don't think is the healthiest thing,
but it definitely got me a whole lot faster,
really quick.
And my gym,
you know,
cause uh,
I had,
I had two arts,
I wasn't going to make it.
When you came in there were sparring three times a week,
what did you,
how did you change that program?
I just asked for the guys to spar hard once a week and still controlled sparring
though with that and I give them,
I give them four rules,
I asked them to follow for will show up on time,
get better,
get tired,
take care of partner.
They do those four things and we're good in,
in,
in all drills,
especially in sport as well.
So he's got to make sure that you're taking care of the guy because he's going
to be there and help you the next day and so on,
which we understand that.
Sportsmanship,
celebrating on shots when you can.
Yeah,
and and decently on shots when you at definitely not knocking each other out.
If he's got,
if you've got them hurt then you know,
relax a little bit,
let them let them off the Pella,
don't finish them.
If it's a body shot,
just touch the head a little bit.
If the headshot and he rocked him and I just didn't touch the body or I will ask
my guys,
do also as if they hurt the guy.
Now if I hurt you now I'm on defense now you got to fight out of it and I'm just
working on a defense and things like that just to make sure he's not keep
getting punched and punch punch.
That's smart.
You got a king but work on something.
You got to switch it.
If I,
if I,
if I rock you,
I'm on defense now you've got to find out of it because that's what's going to
happen.
That's a likely scenario.
So I tried to take a whole bunch of typical scenarios,
fuck,
relax to go scenarios that happen in the fight and pull them into the gym.
That's it.
And you just watch it float down.
I'll set a,
Oh,
set a goal and create a handicap.
Picked out would be the handicapped,
the handicapped with me.
I can't throw it back to the goal is for you to fire back out of being,
you know you being rocked or you were going to kind of right hand stain.
The goal of the drill is for me too is for you to counter my right hand.
The goal is not for me to punch you in the face but get it close enough to the
realistic aspect that he has to properly react to come back with something so
you're just slowing things down,
which is him.
Case for Jujitsu,
Jujitsu is right,
which gives you more attempt to rank plush and I get punched in the face.
You're not freaking out.
Well if I can take away that fear of not freaking out,
getting punched in the face,
they could focus on the proper techniques and what needs to happen so you make
it a part of muscle memory so that if you're in a scenario where things are
getting wild,
your body is automatically gonna move that way in the project.
I want to have that,
that muscle memory,
that subconscious protection in action.
One of the things I found interesting about your system is you've also taken to
account people that are scared to get hit and you've sort of developed this way
to slowly build up their confidence.
Yes.
Correct.
And how do you apply that by,
you know,
we're going to start today and we're going to go 50% this nice and light or at a
pace where you're not going to be scared.
You have to,
if you hate from get scared,
like hey,
he can you slow it down a little bit or I need to make sure I'm there to tell
him to slow it down because I don't see that proper actions out of this guy.
He's for still freaking out.
So you need to slow down.
I'm going to feed 2% okay,
if that's your 50% motherfucker,
then go 10% you know,
like I slept in my bed,
I'm watching the guy.
Uh,
things like that.
But then also just a setting the goals too.
Like my,
the guy who was the back against the wall and this guy just told him straight
shots that again,
the goal at the drill is for him to defend the straight shots.
Not for me to punch in the face,
but even I know it's coming.
You can relax and don't talk as fast as me and the punches.
Ernesto hoost was talking recently.
Perfect.
Mr. Proof of that dude,
one of the greatest kickboxers of all times.
Beautiful to watch him.
And he was talking recently about training and about how some gyms,
they knock each other out in the gym and he's like,
that's ridiculous.
That's just never happened.
He's like,
you,
you don't need to do that to save it for the fight.
And you know,
he's one of the greatest kickboxers ever,
ever.
But he's like,
you're wasting your yourself in the gym because there's certain gyms,
you know,
like a kickboxing.
He was like Mike's gym.
Cause I heard about this mutation,
just wars.
They go to war,
Melvin Manhoef and Badr Hari throwing fucking rocks.
I uh,
learned so much from this place,
a kingdom and may how feel as gym.
But man,
I went down there and I've,
I think I've never been scared to get into there for the second time.
You go in there,
it's full out war,
like really going as hard as you possibly can.
Like seeing people get dropped and stuff and you have to be on your a game and
the next one we're in there for sparring.
It was like I was nervous getting in there,
you know,
cause I was going with bigger dudes too.
I mean they let you split with whoever and there was a guy throwing knees at my
head and uh,
it was insanity and I actually got to spar with Hockfield Cordelia and he
dropped me like twice as his stomach with his push kicked man.
He's got like seriously the best push kick I've ever felt is good.
He's a great boy.
Chaga dropped me like come on my stomach like,
oh you know,
this is like my first fight in the UFC and you just told me up to the sport
needs more masters of the martial arts like that.
Like have hooker Dora.
Absolutely master in the art.
That's awesome.
I just don't know if I agree with that.
Shoot the box way of training.
Crazy.
No I don't,
I don't like that either.
Seems like it's not the best way anymore.
It works with some guys.
You know,
some guys it works for but I think that there's,
there's,
there's certainly something to be said for his results.
I mean you look at the guys who trained Anderson Silva,
fucking Vandelay Silva,
Shogun Ninja.
I mean just mad men.
And I went in there and kind of fit in perfectly because I was just going super
aggressive as well and went really hard,
which I'm glad I learned it not do so when you watch anymore.
But uh,
it was funny cause Bob in there and he's,
instead of using hand wraps,
he's just got his hands duct taped.
You know,
just hard as a rock duck tape.
He's got his shin guards,
duck tape dawn.
He's just scary dude.
And he's like,
what?
After I got done with practice and I'll feel is talking to everyone,
he like had to point out how much he loved my sparring cause I'll hardly went
when it should have been the opposite.
It should be like,
you know,
you need to control it a little bit and you kind of beat up on this guy and you
know.
But instead he was like,
I love it.
You need to come back here more.
You know?
Wow.
It's an animal.
Oh yeah,
he's an animal is an animal.
Guys is tell him I listened.
I kit.
Let's just see the brain cells for the,
for the fight itself and the training.
It's foreign.
Yeah.
I mean it's interesting to different approaches.
Some guys just fucking stump the pedal to the metal and when the wheels fly off
the car.
All right.
I guess we're stopping here,
but he's not,
I mean this Vandelay thing is crazy that's going on right now.
Oh yeah.
I heard it for a random drug test and he bounced.
They tried to get him with a random drug test and he said,
I'm fucking out of here.
And ran out of his house.
I heard us,
I don't know Jim,
Jim,
but he was like,
where's your paperwork?
Who are you?
I've got to go.
I think chills.
The one that said he ran.
Right.
Who knows if he actually did run?
Most likely.
So here's the drought.
Who's chasing Vandelay chase and van was like,
no,
you do.
If you caught him,
shit,
tell him good job.
Hey,
you run quick.
Don't kill me.
Fucking Nevada state athletic commission.
His collector guy can run.
Probably that is the last guy you want to chase.
Oh,
that's hilarious.
And so he said he had some,
he made a video.
So he's got some excuse for why he didn't,
but he's got to work it out with the Nevada state.
That's about the commission.
Whatever they took testosterone offer,
they'd no one could be on testing anymore.
No one is,
well,
he was never on it.
He didn't have an exemption,
so he wasn't on and officially don't you look at me like that Dwayne,
just stretching,
man.
I got us thinking about back.
Okay,
what's that?
I think he's probably had a vitamin or two in his day.
He's healthy.
Yeah.
I think he's,
he works out,
he must work in supplements were involved and then some of his primary
development,
especially early in the day you look at the pride fights,
he was a motherfucker.
Dude.
Pride was so special.
Oh Man.
I want to crazy.
I got to watch some more of those fights.
I get to watch for a price.
We have these gloves.
And I wanted to ask you about these,
cause I asked Brendan Schaub about on the other day,
um,
do you think there's a way
to make a glove that has less finger pokes and and is it a pride glove because
the pride glove has a little bit of a curve curve to the hand.
I think that's the answer because a booster,
they made a pair of gloves that we can open her hand all the way.
I thought that was perfect.
Sea Kelp and of the way that you're going to be less finger poked,
it's all like this.
Yeah.
It just like a little cup,
like a little mitten.
I mean at your fingers still exposed but they just can't open the handle the way
it was sewn on the science.
He just couldn't do it.
Like those little hinge there.
I think that would actually be,
I don't know would help Annie can still,
for the most part you kind of grapple with that monkey gripped anyways.
You don't risk control step when the guy like VRE doom for Dumas is a lot of
risk controls triangle and use your thumb and thought would be fine.
You can use his thumb.
Exactly.
Maybe if your hands are curling and you're going to grab the risks of some while
your hands still going to be curled,
you know he can be to grab it like that.
Yeah.
I guess we never do you use,
you really use individual finger manipulation.
You never do this.
He never interlock your fingers on the Thai clinch.
Yeah and that that's true,
right?
That is true.
Vandelay did used to clinches first together,
but do you think the correct technique tie wise?
It's like this anyway,
but if you want to do this you can but I just,
I dunno.
I just think it's just stronger growth.
Yeah.
I think it's a stronger grip as well.
Like I've seen guys get away with weird grips and take downs,
but you know when you can,
when you lock cries waste,
the Gable grip just feels so right.
It feels like snuggle.
You sucker just love this little guy and you've got so much power in that
position.
It's such a good position.
But um,
yeah,
if they could have something where the fingertips are covered,
we can't poke the eye.
Well they weren't,
they weren't covered.
And then the gloves I seen,
it may be you have to cover,
I'm not sure,
but that they were just pretty much just like this,
but just had a hinge on the science.
We can open it all the way you just place,
you could have it so that the fingertips are somewhere in another covered with
like a softer piece of leather.
Some neoprene.
Yeah,
something along those lines.
Just something that be custom fit gloves to be perfect.
Then I guess each of fighter rough,
the customer pick list,
would that be,
you got a mouthpiece mouthpiece,
why can't you have custom fee and a fight?
They'd have to be measured to the day of the fight for the A and e big cuts and
such like that.
We get some fingers are different lengths but just tight rubber to seems to me
like this.
At least we should be exploring other options.
How many,
I think there's right the,
I think if they can open the hand curve.
Yeah,
boom.
that would be,
I think that would be it.
Yeah,
I think so too.
Like the John Jones,
John is hard,
right?
Sean Jones does that a lot and he's always crew sophomoric.
But yeah,
look,
he's got the greatest physical advantage I've ever seen in the octagon and he's
the smartest ever using it.
I mean he's the best to keep in guys at the end,
but damn was a lot of Ipos and definitely with him for sure.
And he could get away with the same strategy and same style at the fingertips,
recovered it and it would be fine if there was a way to touch foreheads,
he'd still be able to throw those elbows and punches.
I mean he's not trying to do,
to me grabbing the wrist and hands wouldn't it from a distance?
Well it also would make escripts you would actually have more,
more friction,
you know,
if you had a escript and break that yeah,
you'd have if you had like a,
like some sort of a Suede,
something like that.
Like something
was a little bit of traction to it.
Once you lock that up you'd have to leave.
Yeah.
As long as I mean you fingers.
The only difference would be you wouldn't get as much hand cause you would have
like a little meat in between so wouldn't be able to fully long rant anyway.
It's always a bit tricky to grab with the wraps around.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Anything that makes your hands fatter.
But have you tried those Beltour gloves?
No.
No tour has a,
an Everlast that's like curve.
Well there you go.
Yeah.
And it also has more padding over the metacarpal offer,
more support on impacts and to think that it will protect,
you should start keeping
stats on a broken hands.
And I pokes and see who has more obviously in either a organization
Tor had like the first day they use it,
they had an eye poke so the IPOs are still going to be there,
but nobody's broken their hand.
So they had like a gang of people break their hands before.
But with these new gloves,
I don't believe that they've had a hand or had them for,
they've had them for a while.
Wow.
Like A,
I think there was like 11 fights and out of those 11 fights,
no one had the handbrake.
And that was like the first time they'd ever had that.
I should,
I should pay attention to that and give a better,
uh,
accurate assessment of it.
But I love that they're doing something.
Yeah,
absolutely.
I mean these are moneymakers keep them safe.
Yeah.
Also it should be,
there should be a lot of consideration taken into this stuff.
And when you see this a,
the same thing happened over,
I mean,
what's it,
what's the definition of insanity?
Doing the same thing over and over again expecting different results.
When you have these people that are getting poked in the eyes over and over and
over again.
It's like this isn't the only way we can do this.
Guys.
There's,
there's other fucking ways.
All right,
if you guys goggles,
how about you see guys train?
God's trying to get armbars when they have boxing gloves on giant fucking 16
ounce gloves and they'll,
they'll take armbars,
they'll try to do rear naked chokes to do like a halfass room.
Nigga choke.
You can grapple grapple and still not,
I'll be scrolling your idea and I'll throw like a jab or something and he'll
catch my glove between it and you know,
the catch and stop me then hit me.
The first guy I ever saw do it,
uh,
I think was Josh Thompson is a clever veterans.
He choked someone and grab the inside of his own glove and you're allowed to do
that.
You're allowed to grab your own lot of the holes on your own.
Yeah.
You can't hold another dude's glove,
but you could choke the fuck out of a guy with your glove.
And it's like hook underneath it.
They might've changed that.
I don't believe they have though.
Think much harder to beat it and bite your hand off.
Like say I did the Gable grip people.
If I'm a hand off,
like he's using that hidden all the way back.
If you were talked to deepen that wrap underneath,
you're holding on the old leather cord,
you know?
Uh,
after I washed my fight in the first round,
I could have went for the Japanese necktie.
Oh,
you think so?
I could have went for it.
He,
I went on top of some ground and pound it was rushing it and he came into my
half guard.
I could've,
I could've possibly went for the Japanese necktie.
Yeah.
Maybe that would have been crazy.
Especially because the awning,
the awning,
uh,
the video.
Yeah.
Well,
and then also they offered me an extra bonus for her to finish my next fight
with the Japanese necktie.
I told the operator operates,
it's awesome.
I told Albert,
he's like,
all right man,
I'm getting busy.
I'm getting Mrs Gawky with that.
You know,
obviously my fight change,
but I was,
I could have gone for even hilarious.
I love the dark.
Anyways,
I saw that there as well.
I could have gone for it,
but yeah,
for folks who have no idea what we're talking about,
there's a technique called the dark.
It's a very common choke that when a guy has an under hook on you,
his,
his arm is essentially wrapped around your body and you can get your arm
underneath his arm.
It goes,
your forearm goes underneath his armpit and it's slides up past his neck.
Then what you do is you put your other arm over the back of his head and he
class,
behold your bicep.
It's very difficult to put all those things together because most guys recognize
when the arm is underneath the armpit that you're in danger.
So someone developed a technique called the Japanese necktie.
And what it allows you to do is it allows you to clasp your hands together over
the back of the head and never cinch it up on your bicep.
But still it actually becomes an even more effective technique because you trap
the head in the center of your chest and it's a nasty neck crank and TJ and
Danny Castillo and I,
we're all doing this and an audit video and we're going over the technique.
And so that's when Ana came up with this idea of having you have a benefit.
Yeah,
cause I mean I,
I've already fallen in love with it.
I've done it in the gym all the time.
Not to,
I have OT cause I'd go for that.
Darson and like you said,
people try to defend it and then you can still hold on and get that choke.
So it'll also give you a blood choke and hurts really bad hearts bad.
I immediately when I get locked up in that neck,
so stiff.
After you guys rolled that,
he tried to make the man and now he's like,
all right,
go hard on this.
You know you've got them in like the Omoplata and then you turned him over and
got him like can a little net crank music where I need to fight out of it.
He's like for like a good like week,
he's like to my neck hurt so bad.
He finishes guy with in Brazil.
He got the head and arm.
Are you an Anaconda or doors?
I remember huck.
He just finished somebody in Brazil.
Go ahead.
Her book?
Yeah,
like he's just so not interested in,
in being on the bottom.
He's not interested.
He's a dominant restaurant.
He's dude's these smashers his top games so hard.
But I was just,
I just wanted him to see it and I was teaching it to a Aubrey's friend Whitney.
I was showing her the technique.
She's really into Jujitsu.
So I was showing her some rubber guard stuff and I just wanted to show it on a
strong guy like Danny,
like watch this shit works.
I tried to get out,
lock a guy up in mission control.
I'm a middle aged comedian,
you know,
fuck off.
Fuck Shit.
This comedian,
the reality is I'm a middle aged comedian.
Fucking Ninja.
Nice boy.
You are for all like pretty stout,
but your legs are so flexible.
Yeah.
Well I've stretched my whole life and we're march learn.
I make sure that I stretch.
I can't do that rubber.
I can't do the rubber.
I mean I could try to,
but to the extent
rubber guard.
Yeah.
Well I could do full lotus.
I can dump a load of sucking,
flatten my legs out like that lie on my stomach,
but I make it.
I make it work.
You know,
I,
when I lift,
especially if I lift legs,
I stretch out for 40 minutes.
Wow.
40 home afterwards.
After I train,
I give,
especially with legs,
you don't,
you can't fuck around with that because that was my,
and butter was my kicking ability.
Like throw all throughout taekwondo of course.
And then when I started kickboxing,
this thing has separated me from a lot of other guys was the dexterity.
Have you seen this fucking guy who's fighting and glory now that is,
um,
uh,
Raymond Daniels.
Have you seen this?
Holy Shit.
He hit a dude with a sidekick jumping,
turning sidekick in the face and knocked the guy out and glory.
One of the wildest combinations in a,
in a kickboxing match I've ever seen.
He dropped the dude with the right hand.
The guy went down and he hit this jumping side,
spinning sidekick in the air,
running the dude's face.
Hold,
tuck.
The whole pull down on a to that up.
It was Raymond Daniels Glory.
Kao It's like one of the greatest kick Kaos.
Evan,
when did you start training in martial arts?
When I was 14,
I took karate.
Well,
I took Kung Fu when I was really young,
but I got serious when I was 14.
I took karate and then,
um,
I went to this taekwondo school from 15 on and that was a Jay Kim Taekwondo
Institute in Boston.
From then on.
It was obsessed from 15 to like 20,
20.
I want to see him.
Uh,
we'll kick someone I was holding that had the path.
That's right.
I think,
guess more videos going.
Yeah.
Well I will do some with you,
man.
Let's do it.
Yeah,
I would love to.
If there's a,
here it is.
Watch this dude.
This shit is ridiculous.
This guy's a bad mother fucker and he's a perfect example.
Why isn't it working?
Here it goes.
Watch this.
Okay.
Alright.
Hello.
Look at you.
The fucking kidding me.
Watch that shit again.
I mean,
that is incredible.
The Oscars,
but that was the wildest taekwondo shit I've ever seen.
Oof,
man.
Do they show that?
Yeah,
but look how good that is,
man.
That dude is wicked.
Gimme one more of those.
So that again,
one more time.
Oh God.
Damn.
That dude's good.
But it's like those type of techniques.
We're just starting to see now and kickboxing and MMA.
Look at this touch.
Bang.
Jumping,
spinning sidekick to the Mug.
I mean,
and then just go right on the Dick.
Bam.
That's fucking,
that's Oscar Martinez.
He's a,
he's a good,
he's a really good way to instruction and Colorado.
Just tell them,
well this fight was in Colorado.
Yeah,
this was in Denver.
I mean the guy's incredible.
But like you're starting to see those techniques and those techniques have
always existed in taekwondo tournament's but when you factor in leg kicks,
when you factor and take downs you,
it's very rare that you see them,
but you're starting to see those things emerged now because once you master all
those other things,
then you have this one thing in your arsenal the other guy doesn't have.
Once your takedown defense is good enough,
you can throw that stuff.
Once you're comfortable with being taken down,
you can do that stuff.
You know?
And when you're comfortable enough with your striking that you get that extra
extra Lucentis,
just that extra gap.
And there's some guys that just have wicked spinning techniques and if you have
those techniques,
but did you see honey Jason Land,
that spinning elbow couple of a couple of times landed that spinning elbow and
it's fight this past weekend.
Sweet timing would just
add another.
It's just another added l train to the elbows.
Obviously we didn't want the pads and such,
but you got to Washington sparring.
Just do a little drills and everything like grinder.
Lb drills don't work the elbows,
but what?
I'm curious to see what spinning elbow history when,
how he trained at the bank.
It was beautiful man.
It was beautiful.
He slipped it in inside of a guy's Jab,
like he slipped.
Okay.
Jab,
slip the jab and went right into when Bam.
I mean it was really nice timing.
Okay.
They'll see what you're seeing.
More of that.
You've seen more spinning back fist and left elbow.
We'll kicks.
I was right elbow I think.
I believe.
I'm going to have to see it again,
but yeah,
sorry.
Oh yeah.
I'm pretty sure he slipped it a left Atlanta,
right elbow know?
Yeah,
slip to his right leg and her right elbow.
She said things like that.
Then we just bounced like combinations and things off each other and we're just
like,
we just did.
We'd take off on some combinations.
You should watch that.
There's a couple of moments in that fight,
especially in the first round when he landed that elbows like dies.
One of the nicest executed spending almost I've ever seen and he'll fix,
you know,
a lot of those.
I was too busy doing a Dwayne Bank seminar.
We didn't get to watch the fights we were doing.
Where were you guys?
The team Alpha male jam at ultimate fitness.
I must've been a mob show.
It was good.
We had a good out for sure.
We did built rankings and stuff too,
so that's pretty cool.
Does anybody,
I'm a black phone.
Your system?
I have one,
a one black,
but other than me,
I guess it gave myself known black Bubba.
Why Mcdonald's in Rochester?
New York.
He's a his,
he's a partner with the Chris Herzog who's one of the main guys in 10th planet.
Oh,
that's awesome man.
So there's only one black,
the black bag.
Yeah.
And then when brought one current brown belt,
which is Tj Dillashaw,
Tj Dillashaw,
I was the only black brown belt.
Yes sir.
Just got it.
Yeah.
Two days ago.
Huge.
Yeah.
I think it is important to set the goal ranking in the structure and and
everything with the curriculum.
I think from the system it's a,
you get something.
Is it a steady progression for people to follow through on things and be
committed to goals as humans are?
Right.
We just committed to goals,
goal oriented.
I had a conversation with that about a dad who was a,
he was like thinking that belts were bullshit.
His kid was taking martial arts and he's like,
you know,
belts are trying to nonsense though,
right?
Like if a guy can beat your ass,
you can beat your ass.
I'm like,
yeah,
but no because it's really good for like you get,
like when I got my blue belt,
I remember I was on a TV show,
but I was happier about getting my blue belt and like almost anything else.
I was like,
man,
I'm not a white belt anymore.
Jitsu.
I remember that and that,
that as a grown man was a big deal to me.
But as a kid that's giant,
awesome to show that a kid can progress and they learn.
They get new belts and names of accomplishment or something huge,
huge.
Just give me my black belt a couple of months ago,
man,
I was happy that I was still having to thinking about that man.
That was just awesome to go from Boston,
from Basra giant Ms Diet for me for sure man.
I'm such a fan of the sport and a fan of him and just left Marsh Larson came up
through the traditional more stars on it and respect or that'd be doing kitchen
Christ since I was eight and then in Thai boxing was 15 so I just martial arts
this meme and it's why I'm here to teach and be a martial artist.
I love the boss route and is really honest about his,
about fights.
Do you know he keeps it real you Jon Jones,
I poke thing.
He was really honest about that and the way said it was really fascinating
because he goes,
look,
he goes,
he's very relaxed in that cage.
She's making things up,
he's doing what he wants to do.
He's not in a panic.
And I was like,
if so if he's doing it,
he's poking in the eye.
It's either intentional or what he's doing is causing it,
is aware it's causing and he's not changing it,
you know?
And he's like,
you know,
I think the guy is a great fighter but this is what I believe.
And I'm like,
wow.
I mean that's what he always does.
He keeps it as real,
as real gets read with them or disagree with them.
You will get 100% what bas Rutten thinks when bas Rutten is talking about.
That's one result we had a strong connection to when we were at training because
I believed he knew what he was doing.
And when he would ask me to do a technique or a combination,
it was from his heart.
And it was something that he chose to tell me cause he fit.
It fit my style.
So we had a great combination,
a great relation.
That's what I fell at.
Tj and I talked.
We have a great man.
It's,
it's fricking awesome.
And I feel like the Bond Boston I have.
Yeah,
we have that as well.
He's not going to bullshit me.
Absolutely.
Did you learn anything from boss about like boss is pretty open about the fact
that he kind of red line is body fucking with
this guy too,
man.
I mean he,
he did too much.
He shouldn't have been 55 pounder.
He was going too hard all the time.
He was too OCD about training.
Being OCD for a coach is all right.
You know you're going to make all your athletes better.
Being OCD as an athlete,
you gotta be careful.
You have to have people around you to make you slow down.
Like Uriah has done a great job with me.
When I got in the gym,
I wouldn't stop.
I'd be in there.
I lived in the gym.
That's all I did.
He's like,
Hey man,
get an escape.
Get out of here.
Go do something.
You know,
have some fun.
Like don't be so like in here always killing yourself because it's going to
hinder you enter your body and your performance.
How valuable is having a guy like your right as a friend and a mentor.
And how weird does that put you in a position because you guys are in the same
weight class now and he wants to be a world champion.
Yeah,
I mean it's crazy,
dude.
He's a good dude.
I mean,
he saw after he lost his umbrella that that quick stoppage that he's willing to
give my name a shout on wall,
like one of the worst things that could happen to you,
you know?
And uh,
so it shows this great character and that's tough for me because I've looked up
to the guy,
I have copied him.
I've done a lot of stuff from my career because of him.
And it's going to be tough if that situation ever comes about.
I mean,
I don't want to have to fight the guy,
you know what I mean?
He's brought me up in the sport.
But it seems like a very honest and open approach that you're taking though.
It's like there's no ego involved there and you're,
you know,
the way you're looking at it as a very healthy yeah.
It's,
you're being very honest about,
um,
him being a mentor.
You even copying a lot of his attributes,
his positive attributes.
Yeah,
it's a tough situation for sure,
man.
I mean,
like I said,
I looked up to him and he,
I mean I owe a lot to him.
To what?
For where I'm at,
I'm talking to you guys right now because here I favor.
Yeah,
I'm sitting here because if he texted me one night and said,
can you come be our trainer?
Yeah.
I owe a lot to that as well.
That is the weirdest thing when it comes to fighters where they trained together
and then they have to fight together.
You know,
even if it's just on a short period of time.
Like I was talking to Brendan Schaub the other night,
train with our Laski quite
a bit,
and now he's fighting him and less than two weeks in Vancouver.
And that's a little bit different situation even into that because I mean
yesterday chain with them a little bit here.
I've done every day
practice underneath Uriah every,
I've been for four years now.
I've been at your eyes,
gym nonstop.
I haven't gone anywhere else to train for.
It was extended period of time.
I've been there.
And uh,
you know,
I was going to be tough when we're,
we're good friends,
you know,
we're like a family.
Everyone in that gym,
we've created little family to where you got that guy's back,
your eyes fight in July 5th,
I would love to go off and take a huge break and,
and relax a little bit,
but I got to come back and help your eye out.
You know,
I've got to get in the gym,
help run some practices and give them some looks and stuff because I care if he
wins or not.
And so since we all care about each other that much that we're gonna hold each
other accountable for being a practice.
And you saw a crazy,
they didn't,
when I won the belt,
you know like they were front row going insane and,
and that,
that made me tear up more than even like me actually went in.
The bell is going back and watch him fight pass and seeing those guys react to
me winning,
you know.
Wow.
So yeah it's a crazy situation that we can be put in but you know,
I mean they want the drama behind the fights.
So I mean maybe if they're willing to shell out the cash,
me,
me and your ill have a smile on her face while fighting.
Wow.
That would be crazy.
Yeah.
You're the extreme opposite end of this,
of this extreme end of the spectrum.
There's The r Lawsky and shop guys who have respect for each other but they
weren't really good friends and there's you and your ride.
We're almost family.
Yeah.
And you're in that situation where you fight in the gym on a regular basis,
do you mean,
I mean,
if the UFC really wants us to watch his fight,
just come to practice,
you know,
just bring a camera crew in.
And that's one thing about me.
Yeah.
Right.
Tuesday,
we both got like this ego thing too,
and we'll throw it down.
I mean,
sometimes we have some sparring matches.
Look like brothers fighting.
I think just keep it,
it man,
like just a ball of craziness going everywhere,
you know?
And uh,
it's fun.
I mean,
that's why we've gotten so much better.
It's pushing each other that hot water wash,
you see fights everyday or every once a week.
Anyway,
this must be a weird position for you to be in,
to be the guy with the video game controller and you see these guys adopting
your techniques and getting better.
Like we,
we've talked about it on the commentary many times was there was a,
there was a jump.
I,
he knows guys were always murderers from the,
you mean from the first time they were in the WEC.
All those guys were murderers.
Benevidez has always been a killer.
Super Slick.
You got a lot of different,
different weapons in his,
in his toolbox.
But then a difference in his striking difference in Chad Mendez striking me,
you know,
all of them,
even if
watched the fights,
if you just look at the stats alone,
you could tell he's made a difference.
You know,
you don't even have to watch the fights too much better.
We've gotten,
just see the punches landed or us finishing fights on our feet now and uh,
you know,
that says it all there too.
Yeah.
We've got to figure out a way to keep you guys together.
This is ridiculous for sure,
man.
Definitely a special time in martial arts history and it really is 100% of that
has to be taken into consideration.
Duane Ludwig,
you can't just fucking fly off to Colorado.
We had a,
we had a practice of the day and he's like,
all right,
my last practice is Tuesday.
Just as like,
oh,
of next year,
right?
Yeah.
Like you just want them to,
no one wants him to go,
man.
I mean,
he created this serious magic.
That's Jim,
but we don't want them to go.
Yeah,
that shit to be worked out.
Let's,
we'll talk later about that.
It needs to be worked out good.
And talk about this later.
Um,
the other guys in the gym,
um,
Chad Mendez is about to fight Joseph Aldo for a second fight.
That's another really intense,
really interesting fight.
Trina guy in Mendez who was always a beast,
but it's clearly gotten better.
Are you going to work with them?
It depends on my,
in my,
uh,
already finished,
at least in my house cause I was uh,
just married,
made a decision to leave June 12th,
because that's when my,
when we signed the lease is over.
So in order subpoena stay,
I'd have to stay for two more months and I got the,
some things happening in Colorado right now with the business and my house out
there.
So I've got to figure some things out if I can stay,
I'm not looking to move twice.
I,
uh,
if we could stay in the house that I was getting,
I'm currently renting,
then just extend the lease.
Then
she made some phone calls.
Can we happen here when we asked for the world title?
Yeah.
You know,
appraiser to be,
if Chad under your tutelage get wins a world.
I think,
I don't think he needs me,
but uh,
I think his chances are better with me.
I want it to be there.
There was a,
um,
it,
it was just a,
the date the date was set before his title was announced.
I think,
um,
for me to leave out,
I was actually,
I'm not my question how much just say what about this situation?
But um,
I didn't think the day,
I didn't pick the date.
Yeah.
Um,
yeah,
but I'm trying to help him stay for sure.
It's definitely good.
He was the guy,
I thought it was going to get the boat first just because I've seen him closer
to the rankings and the other guys.
But then obviously this guy has to go ahead and get bad ass.
It was a Benevides and then Uriah and then Tj now,
now Chan to win in opposite rotation that I was thinking anyway,
but his guy that I felt would get the tower shot,
we'll get the title shot and get the title first and I do believe that he can't
be all though.
Um,
Benevidez is going to probably eventually get another shot and I hope so
man man,
that was,
that was my low as far as being out here tomorrow from l four year and a half.
That was the lowest part.
Lois.
I think for me like that,
that,
that I passionately careful care about my eyes and to see him lose and he's like
that.
I thought that hurt my feelings
for folks who don't know,
Benevidez got caught with a right hand early in the first round and got knocked
out by a guy in mighty mouse Johnson who's probably one of the,
you know,
at least top three guys pound for pound in the world.
But you know Benevidez when he's at his best is right there as well.
That Tim Elliot fight was why the fight man?
I thought or the,
the tighter if I thought for sure he was.
And when the bell,
sure.
His amount is like a God damn mountain on top of you.
That amount.
It's just all these kinds of his pills.
You're locked on top of Elliot and you were like Whoa,
this is a crazy amount.
There's levels of mount,
you know,
there's some guys that like,
cause like Damien Maia and his last fight,
he's got that ridiculous amount.
You know Damien Maia gets on top of you and it's just a little bump.
He just locks down on you and you're like,
you're not bucking that guy off of you and Benevidez with dad.
He gets one arm anywhere near underneath your chin.
So all these guys,
right Blake's to Joe constrict their own C.
Right.
But uh,
he traps both your arms or one year olds.
Just depends if you,
if you have one hand trying to that choke,
you're screwed.
Yeah.
So just such a good job of tracking and with his legs,
he's got such good body control on that.
And uh,
that's why I will never get cotton Nagy teeny anymore,
man.
Cause inhibit favor,
Those guys are killers on the neck.
So I'm sure what the best choke defense ever.
I'm sure the progression of all these guys,
man,
they're all just,
it's just the whole iron sharpens iron.
Like of course I'm getting a bunch of credit for it and I'll take all of it of
course.
But man,
these guys,
I mean the one guy gets better and just shows off to the next grade the next
day.
So it's what you said it best.
Do you have a bunch of race cars?
They were already race cars.
I mean it wasn't like you came around to guys that are just,
you know,
they've only done marathons and I've never thrown a punch in their life.
You know,
you know you're getting like the elite of the elite and you're training them.
Just tuned him up a little bit that that fight with Tim Elliot was the first
time I ever saw a guy tap with his feet.
Yeah.
Both of his arms were trap.
It really was like a fucking,
like a viper.
Like,
oh,
like a snake,
like an anaconda choking.
Someone who just got on top of the fucking shit out.
Yeah.
Wicked,
wicked ground.
That wasn't one of the craziest fights I've watched.
The energy that Elliot brought out and that was,
he's a Gamer hunt.
It was tricky to game plan for him.
It was tricky for me to create what aspect of you is to do the things I thought
were gonna be successful.
He's strong shit,
man.
He's strong as shit and his endurance is incredible and he could take it,
You see that fight with bug routine off.
You fought a,
I leave Boggo teen off and they went to war for fucking three rounds.
He took everything but the kitchen sink from Fargo teen off talking with Tina
off was teeing off on him and [inaudible] was a better striker.
It was smoother and quicker,
but Elliot never kept stopped coming after him.
Never is a Zombie.
Yup.
He's,
and he's very physically strong to like the gout.
No fight.
Ragdolled God,
no around.
Yeah.
He's,
he's strong as fuck man.
For a little dude.
Is he finding Demetrius now see [inaudible] office [inaudible] office fighting
less than two weeks in Vancouver.
It's the main event.
That's a good fight gun.
That's good file.
I want to see if that guy can keep it up and the fourth and fifth right?
Yeah,
because mighty mouse,
he's,
you better be in fucking shape.
You'd better bring your lunch.
I never stopped moving.
It's true.
It's like all the two from familiar guys when they have endless energy.
Do you ever foresee a possible super fight you and mighty mouse?
I wouldn't do that cause it can mighty mouse go up to 35 I can make 25 can you
really?
Holy Shit.
35 pounder.
I mean forcing myself to get big as big as I could possibly get to 155 pounds.
I'm lean.
I mean during camp,
if I'm just like not trying to get big,
not doing the strength conditioning,
uh,
I can get,
I'll be like foreign 48
what do you think mighty mouse walks around at how big he is?
35 49 his biggest if try to get to 20 pounds over,
I bet that his biggest is that normal for most guys?
Probably.
Is it a percentage of body weight?
More than it is?
Yeah.
Maybe percentage of body weight to,
cause the bigger guys can lose more weight.
Yeah.
It's easier for them to lose it.
Um,
but,
and it's also how lean you stayed throughout the year.
I mean I stay really lean,
I mean as,
as possibly as I can.
And so that's why I'm weighing as light as I can.
If I were to get,
if I were to give it,
put some fat on,
sure I can get up in the 60s but that's useless.
Wait,
I got to lose that again to start camp.
If you got like Damon Wayans in the great white hope,
remember when he got that big belly?
Who's the champion?
Because he wasn't to fight a white dude.
He didn't worry about it.
But that's what's cool too.
These guys are close to wait.
So when they're in the gym,
the focus to get better at the martial arts and not just to lose weight.
You know,
so it definitely makes a difference also.
That is a big God damned deal,
man.
The weight cutting.
Yeah.
It's a real dangerous part of our sport.
I think people cut weight too much weight
thrown to yes it does,
right?
Yep.
And when you hear about guys cutting,
you know,
30 pounds like the glace and Tebows of the world,
he's,
he's the most,
the most ridiculous.
That guy weighs one 55 at the weigh in for like five seconds and then you see
him the next day.
85 2085 that's insane.
He's so big.
I don't even feel like I can move if I gained that much weight after weights.
Like I don't know how he does it.
I wonder if it's a,
there's a difference to the composition of each person's body to some people can
get away with it.
Some people can't.
He's got to take like four ivy bags or something.
I don't know.
I don't know what he did,
but I've heard a four.
I've heard of guys talking before.
Yeah.
I've heard of guys taking blood out,
weighing in and putting the blood back in their body.
Oh Wow.
Yeah.
That was back in the dark days.
Hotel Room.
Fucking intravenous blood.
She's replenishing
some darkness once you started using needles and replenishing fluids and like
what are we doing exactly.
That's crazy.
Is there a way though?
Here's the question.
Here's the two gloves.
Here's a difference between the everglades club,
more padding on the top and that padding apparently is helping people keep from
breaking their hands on impacts
within it.
They're less knockouts.
Um,
I don't know.
That's a good question.
When they did the kid,
when Max,
the middleweight,
they specifically pulled in eight ounce gloves and ounce Rayez,
which is just kind of a horse.
They just moved the out of the way and it's just tape,
gauze and two pieces of leather.
No way less padding in it and then raise glove.
Then there,
then there,
there's an MMA gloves for sure,
but there's more padding on my Shin Sun.
Yeah,
right.
Elbows to,
yeah,
exactly.
Hell,
but God damn.
Especially like you seen in lion fight more than you're seeing glory because
those guys are allowed to throw elbows.
Guys getting cut up man.
I only landed like
a good five or six elbows in that fight in my elbow hurts so bad still.
I was like tender to touch it,
you know.
Well a lot of guys have to get shit like a Bursa sac.
Like you don't really like it burns in there.
Oh is it a did to get it checked out at all?
No,
not yet.
I haven't seriously.
I haven't had any time to do anything since I've been home since just fighting
mad whirlwind.
It's been,
it's been awesome but it's been crazy.
Just,
you know,
obviously interview after interview TV shows,
radio shows.
I mean I'm loving it.
I mean obviously it's the attention you want because this is how you get paid
more and this is what you've been working for.
But it's been a whirlwind man.
It's been,
it's been craziness.
I,
I was more busy now than
it was in camp.
Is there a way to,
uh,
have it so that guys fight at their actual weight?
Is there a way?
I don't think so.
Yeah.
I,
I doubt it.
No matter what.
People are going to do something to take it to advantage somehow the way costs
are enough to,
well I guess the way,
cause it's very now between a couple of doors away in,
in Wayne in an hour before you fight or not even weighing in like before you
walk out to the octagon,
step you on the scale,
you know,
what'd you do if someone was over?
We said it'd be a shame.
That's true.
They have to be 24 hours.
So those all those dishes out of the way.
It's true.
Yeah.
But that would be interesting man.
If you could put it on the fighter,
like where the audience would know that when the guy got on the scale that shows
it to the whole crowd.
Yeah.
Two Oh three five two oh 3.2 that just kind of,
yeah.
Yeah.
Well they have a backup fighter.
You know,
Chelsea did not make weight,
you know,
and then another guy gets up ratio shogun who way over there.
Put the check down.
Here we go.
Right.
Imagine if they had two guys you had to like,
like when you do Broadway,
you have someone who's a a backup singer,
but what do they call them?
An understudy?
Yeah,
and understanding.
you do.
Like you guys don't know Broadway,
so I guess that's what they do.
They have the actor and then there's an understudy for the actor in case the
act,
it take sick to understanding can always step in.
And if I was the understudy,
every put advising and that guy's water and like,
you know what I mean?
Like,
oh,
you're sick.
I'm in.
What?
Despise him,
dude.
Your wife gives you the shits like ridiculous or make it makes you feel like flu
symptoms really.
Supposedly.
Yeah.
You put the vice dean and someone's water,
it'll mess you up.
Shouldn't have probably broadcast that on the Internet.
Oh,
assholes all across the country
are with them and mentally break them.
Danny Castillo was at the fucking cvs.
You can have a big bag of by know.
How much time do you have now before you'll go back into training again?
And when do you think you'll,
you'll have the first defense of your title?
I'm not sure.
I got to obviously go in and talk to Dana with that and stuff to us says false.
Oh really?
Yes it does.
A mythbusters.
I guess there's something.
No,
it's just the internet and you want to drink some level.
This is a way though.
If you didn't use vaccine,
you could use something else.
Obviously some nasty shit you go good.
Let do is drop byZ and your shit now he'd be like,
nothing's hiring.
I'm fucking immune to that.
Yeah,
I don't,
I don't think it'd be Borow.
Um,
I doubt it.
I mean if I would have knocked him out in the first round and finished and then
I think I would have got an instant rematch with him,
but,
uh,
I feel like,
cause I dominated him for five rounds,
that they'll make him work his way back up.
At least that's my thought.
I don't know.
But isn't it about business for sure at this point.
And if you decided to have a rematch with him in Brazil,
like that's what his coach is saying.
You know,
if he was man enough come down to Brazil.
Yeah,
yeah.
Andre Pinera said that,
right?
Yeah.
You got to respect that.
He has to say that.
Of course it's going to say
that Dwayne would say that too.
What's your title?
And it took a few,
you know,
come on Sacramento Bitch.
You know what would be said?
So all that aside,
you know,
from a business standpoint,
if you could get out of Brazil alive,
I think that would be a good move.
No,
but yeah,
I don't know.
I Guess Better Vegas,
I'd really,
I'd find a five Vegas or somewhere like that.
I mean the champ.
Yeah,
that's true.
I mean Brazil is a,
I love Brazil.
I went down there vacation,
loved it,
went down there,
fought hey.
You know,
it was all right.
I feel like I feel like the fan,
so I'm not saying that like the judges do it on purpose or anything,
but I feel like the fans play a huge part in scoring in scoring cards down
there.
Yeah.
But look you,
there's been some bad decisions against Brazilians in Brazil.
Like okay,
Phil Davis and Leo Machida.
Yeah.
I did not think to Phil Davis won that fight.
I thought it was a very close fight,
but I thought Liotta Machita wanted to,
I thought if it is in Brazil for surely Odo got the,
got the nod,
but when they gave it to Phil Davis,
I was like,
wow,
that's interesting.
I wonder if maybe they hear that they're biased and they're embarrassed by that.
So they try to fight against it and you know,
I don't know.
But you're the champ.
So Vegas,
it is
reason judges should all the trainer be martial artists?
Hundred percent.
Yeah,
that's for sure.
What do you think could be done to improve the scoring system?
I know with your mad mind,
you've probably sat down and thought about that as well,
just to bring it a martial artist.
I understand the system being educated,
but do you think the 10 nines are just too prevalent?
Oh guys get knocked down like the first round your fight.
What's a fucking for sure a ten eight round.
How many guys put in ten eight though?
Did you even look at the car?
Not One of them.
Not One.
That's insane.
And when other,
the crazy thing is,
is one of the judges gave the second round of brow.
That's the same too.
I heard about that too.
But the knockdown that you fucked that guy's world up in that round,
that's as close to getting stopped did you can get and not get stopped and you
didn't get a ten eight well then the system's broke.
Your staff should be a tenant just like a when Danica steel or dropped Edson
Barboza and December in Sacramento.
That wasn't a ten eight ten nine well,
I support Muslim when a decision,
but that it would have been today.
Draw.
Yeah.
He beat the fuck out of Edson Barboza in that first round.
I mean rocked in with that right hand and pounded on him for the whole round.
Yep.
How's that?
Not a ten eight they should,
it should have been tonight.
Yeah,
no doubt.
They need to do more.
Ten eight so that should have been it tonight for sure though.
Yeah.
I've had conversations with people about ten eight ten nine rounds and I just
don't get it.
Like somebody told me that the first round of Frankie Edgar and gray Maynard was
a ten nine round.
I go,
what the fuck are you talking about?
I think there's gray Maynard hit him with everything,
but the goddamn kitchen sink had him falling over backwards twice costs back in
one round.
I don't know what to do.
What they do,
they have meetings and they all get together and they say,
okay,
this is how you score it,
so we should look for us.
It goes on.
Are they just pulling people in an office,
an office cubicle?
I don't know.
I mean they have a new guy who's the director of the Athletic Commission now.
Let's see if they change things up at all to call me.
I'll change that shit up for Duane Ludwig.
Come in with the bank system at least for offers.
My guidance anyway,
that's,
I can do well.
Wheat
for folks who don't know,
we stole a system from boxing.
Boxing has a 10 point mustards and we just sort of adopted that system for
scoring,
but it's,
I don't think it's comprehensive enough for MMA because there's so many
different rules are so many different techniques rather than her in play and you
have to be subjective about what is more valuable.
In boxing,
a punch is a punch.
There is left hooks and jabs and right hands.
If a guy lands harder punches and more punches,
he's clearly winning,
but in MMA becomes subjective.
If a guy lands a hard punch,
but you take him down in almost guillotine him who won,
who won that exchange?
It's very tricky.
If a guy lands a good jab but the other guy fucks him up with a leg kick,
a lot of people won't count that leg kick.
Yeah,
they could count over that for sure.
It should get hit with each of them and then you'll be able to know.
That's the thing.
Some guys have said like there was a one judge,
I'll leave him nameless,
but he gets clowned around on all the time on the Internet,
but he said leg kicks don't end fights like,
are you fucking crazy?
Has No one ever leg kicked you?
That's the only way I can eat teach.
I TJ cry when my massage lady rubbed my it band and Zack,
this bitch goes into my it bands with her elbow and I'm ready to tie.
I mean the agony.
You think about a guy like Pat Barry slamming fucking Shinzen into that.
He stopped guys with leg cramps.
Edson Barboza stopped too fucking worldclass MMA fighters with with leg kicks.
Yeah.
Including hot fail all of era.
Who's a fucking longterm MMA fighter.
He's a real veteran.
Stopped him with leg kicks.
That's so dumb.
Oh yeah.
But those won't count as much as a punch.
Sometimes even a punch that doesn't even rock a guy.
He's just got to come back to people being martial arts and training in it and
understanding all the athletic commission.
People fight each other,
find out gloves and just as traveling,
one of those things,
you have to be able to speak the language to understand it,
and if you just know the words and what the words mean,
you're not gonna understand them in the context of the flow of the movement.
It's like if you taught me a bunch of words in Spanish and then a bunch of
people were talking,
I'm not necessarily going to get the gist of the conversation.
Even if I know what those words in Spanish are and go,
oh,
okay.
He said,
fuck your mother.
Your mother's a whore.
Pluto.
That's a whore.
You know?
Puta.
Okay,
I got it.
I know what he said.
That's essentially what's going on.
When you're seeing these guys and they're,
they're,
they're judging fights.
These guys,
they don't understand the flow.
They don't understand who's in danger.
The owner stand a transition.
They understand what's going on.
Like,
oh,
he's in a dominant spot now,
or no,
this guy's like super close to being finished.
The problem I see with the Athletic Commission people training is if they
trained somewhere that a guy's fighting from that gym,
you know,
so they can't train anywhere.
We're fighters train.
So they'd have to,
you know,
how do you do that?
How do you get them to train?
So it was a man academies though.
There's a man that kind of state athletic commission training centers or
something
or even even the way they still,
it's business,
you know,
it's just how it is.
Like you just,
you can't sway the either way.
That'd be a professional.
But of course that would come into play.
I see that.
Yeah.
There's no doubt.
I think,
um,
that could be an issue,
but guy should be examined and when something like that comes up,
they should be,
they should have a conversation with the class or experience.
When you see a really bad score card,
that guy should be forced to sit down and watch a fight and explain what he
thought.
What did he just,
you know,
like I've had,
I've had conversations with people that gave the first round GSP Hendricks.
They gave that first round of GSP.
I said,
let's watch that fight and you,
let's watch this around.
And you tell me how he won that first round.
Did he win it because he didn't come anywhere close to getting a gay teen?
Did he win it because there was a take down for a brief moment they were
scrambling on the ground or do you want to look at damage?
Look at the fact that he couldn't take the Hendricks down.
Hendrickson's pummeling them with left hands to the face in the clinch,
battering his legs with knees.
Like,
do you not see those?
what's going on here is no one ever need your leg.
And now,
uh,
the judges,
they don't watch the TV's right.
They watch too.
Sometimes we,
we had it set up in,
in Nevada and a lot of the fights where they're allowed to use,
I feel like they should.
Very important,
very important stuff.
You couldn't see if you weren't able to watch the TV wall commentating.
I miss it all the time.
I missed strikes if I try to watch it live as much as possible because I feel
like first of all it's the coolest shit ever fight live,
you know?
And it'd be ridiculous.
I have the greatest job in the world and I'm not even allowed to see it live.
I have to look at a little CV,
you know,
not even a big one,
a little one too fucking little ass TV right in front of you.
And when I'm watching it sometimes like there'll be a moment where like the guys
back is to me and he'll throw a punch in the guys in front of him and the guy
drops and you can't see what happened.
And so you have to watch it in the monitor and,
and check it.
But for a judge for the longest time they didn't have that.
So like say if a guy jumps,
jumps guard and is attacking a Komora and it's got a guy's arm locked up and
it's starting to pin it.
If you're looking from the wrong position,
you don't understand Jujitsu.
Say,
if you're on the other side and your the same level as the cage and you're all
the way on the other side of the cage,
you can't even see if that guy's arms getting jacked.
There's shit you're not going to catch up.
Like I've actually talked to judges who do train,
who told me that other judges have said to them in the middle of a fight,
what is he doing?
What is this?
What's going on here?
Which is fucking crazy.
It's crazy.
Highest level of the sport,
the highest level.
It's being judged by people who literally don't know what's happening,
which is crazy.
It goes,
it goes back to they need to train or do seminars and be accountable and even
the people that know are aren't using the points.
It's ten nine ten nine 10 everything's fucking ten nine yeah,
I mean you got to die in the cage to get a ten seven I mean,
what happens?
How does someone ever get a ten seven what happens?
What has to happen to be pretty to be a ten seven that could have been a 10
seller freaking I had to.
Great.
Great Maynard.
No question.
Should have been like that and there should have been a ten seven I don't,
I don't know the exact scoring by each and every judge,
but I had to say tonight I had a conversation.
10 is that crazy?
That's crazy.
I had a conversation with a judge who was arguing me that it was a 10,
nine.
He was actually arguing.
I was like,
this is,
and he's a judge.
I was like,
this is the craziest conversation I've ever heard.
I can't even talk to you.
You're a crazy person.
Like this is why it's,
it's got to be quantifiable because a guy can just squeak by.
There's oftentimes rounds where you go,
oh,
I'm going to give it to Ludwig.
It was so close and they'll do a 10,
nine Ludwig,
but it could have been a 10,
nine this guy too,
it's just like so close.
And then there's gray Maynard,
Frankie Edgar first fight,
you know,
which is like,
come on on those,
on those like really bad scoring.
Does she decisions,
uh,
when they like really mess up?
How has that person that lose their job?
Like it,
just like with any other gel,
if you're working at office Max and you mess up someone's giant printing
operation or whatever it is,
you're going to get fired.
Like,
why can't you,
why don't they get fired for making a horrible decision?
Part of the problem is that in order to get fired,
you have to admit you fucked up.
So you have to admit you hired someone who was incompetent.
So if you fired an incompetent person,
then they have to review that person's job and their employment record and go,
okay,
how long has this guy has been employed by you?
And let's look at some of their other fights that happened with the packing out
Timothy Bradley fight.
You know,
everybody was fucking so angry at this one judge that she resigned from being a
judge.
But then they started looking at her past and she has made some fucking
ridiculous calls.
We just really bad,
bad,
bad decisions.
And you're like,
what the fuck is going on here?
It's,
they don't want to admit that they hired in competent person and Kaiser was
fucking really,
really defensive about it.
Like I brought it up several times and they have terrible judging and he would,
instead of that,
he would like bring up fights where I thought a guy won and the consensus was
that the other guy won like online and on the underground or something like
that.
Didn't talk about it like in a,
in a very rational way.
Like,
well yeah,
well you do wrong some dorms to your opinions about right and now we're,
we're talking about like real obvious travesties of justice and he would be in
denial about the need for change.
Then you'd have to take into account people's gambling and maybe if they're
betting on the,
Ooh,
interesting.
Well that's what people were alleging and a,
an inquiring about when it came to this one particular boxing judge because some
of the decisions are so egregious that people were like,
what does cause there can be money made and with folks don't know.
There's a bunch of different options that you could bet on when you bet on a
fight.
They could be,
you could bet on over unders,
you can bet on unanimous decisions as opposed to majority of decisions.
If you could conceivably bribe someone to the point where they would make a bad
decision and that way the person would still win.
So it wouldn't be too much of an outrage like a manual packout dominating
Timothy Bradley still win,
but you give it to him,
you give one,
one guy gives it to to Bradley and this way this person gets a chunk of cash.
Manny Pacquiao is still wins the fight,
but then they,
you know,
when it comes down to like the bedding,
it's not a unanimous decision.
It's a split decision.
So some of bets,
a split decision they fucking clean up cause they bribed a judge.
I'm not saying that that's happened,
but that is one way you could do it for sure,
but you get a decision like that Pacquiao Bradley five were but Bradley beat
pack out and everybody was like,
what the fuck?
No Bradley didn't win that fight.
Like everybody was going crazy after that fight.
You watched that fight.
Manny Pacquiao outboxes Timothy Bradley.
It's a pretty clear,
yeah,
100% so you ever go,
you always got to wonder how is it possible that 99% of boxing experts have one
opinion,
but yet people who are professional boxing judges fuck it up.
And with MMA,
I think it's up to interpretation,
unquestionably.
Right?
But in MMA,
I think it's a lot like with his Jack Slack fellows,
there's guys like that out there that really know their shit.
Those are the guys that you'd be judging.
There's,
they shut to pass an Iq test.
Everything.
I mean that guy guaranteed macro check.
How many goddamn judges are there?
I mean the sh
three for fight,
but I mean how many of them total is there?
20 as the 30 boy.
If you had like an like a big conference and brought in super fans from all over
the world,
figured out who was,
who knows their shit,
let's make them watch a fight.
You'd tell me what's going on in this fight and really an extensive,
you know,
a really exhaustive process.
You could have an amazing,
I got my buddy Mike Temple who watches it,
the fights of the guys that does a breakdown for me or does it bring it up for
them as well?
It breaks down.
Tj Is,
you know,
strengths,
weaknesses,
and then also breaks down.
They pull on the strengths and weaknesses and how we can do to capitalize on
these things.
So I get looks from other people as well as my buddy's a superfan and he'd be an
excellent judge,
a referee,
maybe.
I refute the judge for sure.
I think there would be a lot,
a lot of guys like that.
There's a lot of guys like that,
so that's me,
man.
I love breaking film down in just figuring out ways to do things,
you know?
That's fun.
Yeah,
no doubt.
But the thing with you though is that you'd have to watch the fight sober and
you'd have to watch the white stone freeways and on Alpha Brain Alpha brain.
When,
when you watch a fight,
what are you,
what are you looking for?
Are you looking for specific moments in the fight where you see vulnerability or
do you look at it one way,
the first pass and the second time?
Do you look at it more in detail?
Like one time look at offensively,
one time,
offensively,
defensively what they're doing,
which were their step.
And we're sort of course we didn't want to strikes how they react to certain
combinations,
where they do with the idiosyncrasies,
where they're doing with it,
when they're tired,
when they have their wings,
when they're feeling confident.
Um,
there's plenty of ways to look at it,
look at the fight.
But I always look at it with my guys winning and where the holes are going to
be.
Like if a guy is good,
let's say if you guys are good at left Tuck,
I want to do something to make them feel the left took Etsu perfect analogy.
I went down hard.
He dropped me a left hook,
right?
But,
uh,
um,
I tried to pick up their strengths and then make them do a strengths.
Hannah morale spin kick,
right?
He's really good at it.
Well let's make them do it.
So we already know we are expect or making them do a snow.
We're actually one step ahead,
things like that.
But as far as bringing down the fight itself,
there's,
there's plenty of things you could pick up on Washington by that.
There's the guy,
oh,
he was,
he was supposed to fight holds with first,
but it can switch to Chico was something big with him is in the middle of the
third round and every fight,
if it's a subconscious thing or not,
he breaks mentally.
He brings in the middle of the segment has been the,
I forgot the guy's name is a Korean or Chinese guy.
He was waiting,
he supposed to fight Holdsworth chicken came in.
Dude,
I forgot his name either.
Yeah,
I forgot his name.
But anyway,
he fought Chico Chico come loose in Milwaukee.
But uh,
he didn't with take downs his,
uh,
in the middle of each fight,
in the middle of the dead,
middle of each fight,
he physically broke.
I don't know if was mentally and physically.
So it's just things like that is,
you know the guy,
the guy who we can capitalize on him dropping his jab but come over the top of
the right hand or who couldn't,
you know him.
Yeah.
There's don't seem to see that people do,
whether they're aware of it or not.
Do you think sometimes people see the finish line and they start to slack off?
You mean like Tj didn't do like teacher,
I didn't do it.
All the gas
downshift and he wanted me to come
fifth round,
obviously moved my feet faint and be safe.
Obviously I hadn't tried to fight one and for me what I did and that fifth round
was slow for me.
I came out I think 30 45 seconds I didn't engage,
but as soon as he started coming at me,
it's like I can't,
I can't do it.
I mean,
if I'm going to be my best fighter I got to do,
I don't want to relax too much.
I don't want to be like,
all right,
I one kind of chill defense mode because you're going to get caught.
You're going to get beat because you're not at your best.
I want to write,
I need to do what I do best.
And that's how I and I get caught.
That's a,
that's a very important point.
Pull up that fight.
Brion pull up the,
the final sequence where Tj a knocks out Barao cause you,
you didn't do anything differently than you had done from the first round.
You just use,
every time you saw an opening,
you just kept attacking Kevin.
Dang.
So you stayed sharp.
That's an important thing to not,
not slack off when you see that finish line.
So people have a tendency to do that,
right?
They see the finish line,
they start thinking instead of fighting it
defense mode,
I feel like,
so Danny Castillo do this against Barbosa.
He went out there and demolished him the first shot.
And then the first thing I was,
was scared because I knew Danny was going to sit on a lead and I was afraid of
that.
And,
uh,
obviously Danny knows that now and he's,
you know,
he's aware of it,
but he,
that's what he did.
He went into defense mode he wanted,
and he was like,
all right,
I got this fight.
Just be safe,
you know,
and that hinders your performance.
Then he lit every time.
But at some of us have landed to kick is his conference meeting,
went back up.
He had him broke.
If you were to count there in the second round and did the exact same thing in
the first round,
the fire would have been over.
He would have finished in that round.
But instead he lets him come back in the fight,
let them land a couple spin kicks and lend some leg kicks.
Cars has confidence back in the fight changed,
you know?
Yeah,
yeah.
That's interesting,
isn't it?
It's when you watch that first round two,
that was sort of a harbinger of things to come.
And then you saw Danny and his last fight who,
who was,
who did he fight?
He knocked out with one part of the grid and then Jack,
God damn,
that right hand he hit Brennaman with Holy Shit.
Was that impressive?
Awesome.
Perfect timing.
Perfect.
Just we'll just close the distance perfectly and just landed like with
everything from the toes
and you could see how happy was man.
He was so happy.
What was cool is he didn't follow up with that and that and that's like all
right man.
And when he was already out,
so that was definitely cool to see the heels out in and pull that last punch.
So didn't hit.
That was very cool.
And you could see by the impact,
like here's the,
here's the final combination.
Dude.
That's just you.
You fucking stepping over to the left away from the shot.
Look at this.
I love how I bounced off.
I've watched it a couple of times now.
I bounced off the cage.
Yeah,
you shoulda checked the cable.
The hardest overhand left.
I didn't even know I can throw it over and lift that hard dude.
That was solid.
Yeah.
What a combination.
Slipping,
coming back.
I like going back and watching the tape and finally remembering stuff you did.
Is it hard like to,
I mean,
I don't know if this makes any sense at all,
but is it hard to live in the moment after something like this or you like in
the middle of the train and going,
holy fucking shit that I really knock out Borow like are you like when you're
training,
when you're hitting the pads,
when you move from like am I really the fucking barely I champion Tj Dillashaw
takes a while to get,
I mean,
it's still kicking in,
you know what I mean?
It's only been,
what,
nine days?
It's,
it's crazy dude.
It's a crazy ride.
I mean it hasn't even,
I don't even think it's fully kicked in yet.
You know what I just did,
you know what I mean?
Everyone was obviously counting me out except for my team and myself.
And so to make that kind of statement,
it's still kind of,
I mean to hear you say what you say and to watch it again on,
on the,
um,
the fights and just kind of like,
Holy Shit.
Well,
what's interesting to me is not just what you did,
it's how quick you improved from your time in the ultimate fighter and how much
potential you have.
And how interesting.
This is what Dwayne said is so true that we're at a really unique time in the
evolution of mixed martial arts and we're seeing these Jon Jones characters are
taking things to this totally new place where you know,
you've seen creativity,
this abundance of different techniques that they have available to them inside
the octagon and you're seeing accelerations in every single place.
Whether it's Jujitsu,
you're seeing accelerations in the striking,
you seeing everything is starting to pick up,
you know.
And that to me was a milestone fight because it was like so tactical and it was
such an obvious,
an obvious influence of like you as a trainer,
there was,
it was,
you could see it in the fight,
you can see it in the movement.
Like I know you have this very unique way of teaching punches in combination
with footsteps and movement.
So,
and I was watching this,
having seen you hit the pads and having,
you know,
having seen you coach with that and watching it take place.
Oh,
it was amazing
having that conversation that we had at lunch,
before the fight and then watching what you said take place.
You know,
I remember thinking,
man,
wow,
this is so bizarre.
Almost as if you could predict the future right out.
Well,
if you do your homework and you do it right,
it's like if you had to do,
you know,
Jujitsu with a,
a white belt who didn't work out and say,
well,
here's what's going to happen.
I'm going to grab him a clinch.
I'm about to take him to the ground.
Uh,
I'm a arm triangle.
You know,
what's he gonna do?
He doesn't know what the fuck you going to do.
And he's gay.
He's not,
he doesn't know.
He can't.
But at a certain level to say that it gets crazy.
Yeah.
Like when someone has no idea what you're going to do and your,
you know,
a Jocko Ra Sousa,
you could kind of do whatever you want to them.
But it's when the guy's hen and Borow and you say,
well,
was going to do,
is going to fall for faints and the teacher's going to be constantly stepping to
move into,
you know,
once that happens,
then it's really crazy.
Then you watch it and it's,
it's so it's like,
okay,
Yep.
This is the next evolutionary step drilled.
I guarantee you,
you know,
look,
Barao was going to come back.
Better fucking for sure.
Fucking for sure they're going to watch that fight.
You know,
they're gonna,
they're gonna see what they did wrong and browse going to come back and he's
going to light somebody else on fire and demand a rematch and it's going to be
crazy down the line.
Awesome.
That's how it always is,
right.
I had the sports,
so good man.
I mean,
that's why it's,
uh,
it's nerve wrecking.
It's exciting.
It's like everyone's getting better all at the same time because I beat him.
He's going to give him better than you already was,
which is hard to believe,
you know?
Yeah.
They need each other,
you know,
let her needed Duran.
Lennar needed.
Tommy Hearns.
Holly needed Frasier.
Yeah.
Everybody needs that rival.
That's part of not happening.
You also have it in the gym as well,
which is that credible?
I don't think boxing had that that much.
You know,
I think boxing's not as much of a team sport.
It's more individual.
It's cause wrestlers got involved.
Yeah,
it is.
Right.
We turned ours into a wrestling team.
We seriously just have a wrestling team at our gym and I feel like the exact
same feelings when I was in college.
That's interesting because if you remember right,
like when like Marvin Hagler was the champ,
you never really heard a lot about Hagler sparring partners.
You know like Hagler comes from a team of animals and you know,
in this area of Massachusetts and they all get together and Brockton,
blockbuster,
they all can fire up and live together in a house and get the fuck Outta here.
There's none of that in boxing.
Very rarely do you have that in boxing.
You know,
you have camps like Robert Garcia's camp.
They're pretty tight,
you know,
pretty roaches camp.
They're pretty tight starting now.
Maybe they,
they see the benefit of it.
What other martial arts,
uh,
is their teams the time when we tie team?
Yeah.
Moy,
Tai,
you know,
if you fight for a certain gym,
like if you're on Mike's gym guy,
those guys all come out to the cage together.
Golden Glory guys.
Yeah.
Do they actually do like a duel?
I mean,
I know there's like IFC,
we had those,
those kickboxing matches and you keep score and everything,
but is there like a dual match like this team versus team and you keep the score
for matches?
A good question.
Can we as a team,
like you can win a national championship as a team.
They'd done that.
He started that mirror.
Chuck Norris had that world yet.
Boxing League or something like that.
But that's where Raymond Daniels emerged.
That's right.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
That's where people first got to see that guy that won that fight with that
crazy jumping,
spinning kick.
Yeah.
Chuck had a cool idea for it to those the maths with no ropes,
you know?
Oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Sort of like a dish from almost butts round.
Frank shamrock did that for a while too.
Do you remember?
Oh,
he had a shoe.
Oh yeah,
it was it shoe box or something along those lines.
Yeah,
he had like a,
like a pit and I don't look at and then,
um,
yama pit.
They tried to do that.
I remember,
I know the uh,
the original founders of,
uh,
the,
the UFC like Bob Myerwitz.
Okay.
Tried come back with some
new thing,
some yama pitch thing.
Yeah.
It was a couple of years back.
Okay.
Like,
um,
some,
some good guys Fonda in it,
you know,
it was like,
um,
I don't know if Pat Smith,
I want to say Pat Smith,
Florida.
There was some guys that were like good fighters.
It just,
just below like UFC level.
Oh,
just seen this.
This is fucking team.
This is not,
to me,
this is a case is a fight.
I don't like this.
It's dangerous.
Guys are stomping out or what?
What happened?
Well,
they fight.
Yeah,
you tap out or he get submitted.
But this isn't marsh.
It's crazy because guys come over and soccer kicked guys in their head,
whether in a headlock with another dude like these champions are beating on this
guy.
Look at this.
Three guys,
three guys came over and stomped this guy.
Where's this done at?
Brusher it gives zero fucks in Russia and these guys would get beat up.
They get beat up fucking bad.
It's one thing to get beat up by one dude,
but three dudes stomping you when you're on the ground.
Yeah.
That's why I feel as lost in today,
especially in mixed martial arts as the traditional martial arts honor,
respect.
I think that's something that I helped bring to the camp and then,
and it's just kind of a thing.
It helps people keep willing,
accountable,
you know,
shut up no more.
That's about enough to my watch.
That shit.
It's not,
it's not an MMA,
it's an assault.
I agree with you and those guys should be arrested.
I mean,
the whole idea of of MMA is,
you know,
one guy against another guy trying to establish who's trained the harvest,
who's got the best set of skills when another guy's kicking your head and you're
holding on the guys head locked.
What?
What does that prove?
That's assault proves that someone made us a silly show.
They showed two guys can knock the fuck out of one guy.
Yeah,
we can own that for a long time.
That fighting shouldn't be a team sport.
Like that sort of proves if you got to do something like that and she'd be one
guy versus two guys,
I'll be down for that.
If you got one bad motherfucker.
He like one Badr Hari and to you know,
fat soccer players
like to pay to see that for sure.
You guys don't have MMA training but think they could pull it off,
you know,
and one MMA fighter.
Yeah.
I need
three.
He might need at least three guys to make that even competitive.
They don't know any MMA and all that mad fucking bum rush of athletic dudes.
That would be,
that would be profit.
Reminds me of my dad when we were younger.
My older brother,
he'd always have his friends come over and my dad's just,
this old wrestler is super strong and he would just,
uh,
take them all on and have them all pin on the floor at the same time.
And it was screwing it up because they have no idea how to wrestle.
And my older brother and his friends never wrestled.
So it's just like he can hold them all down and manipulate them.
These are grown men and stuff too.
It's hilarious to see,
you know,
so that's,
I mean,
they would need more than three guys to do that to some of the really well
trained,
you know.
Do you teach your old man choke holds?
I mean,
he,
he uh,
he loves the sport man are awesome.
They love it.
They got into a big time.
Um,
my dad's the one that's made me who I am,
you know,
he's the one that made me so great.
My mom,
me,
super competitive and,
uh,
my dad comes to the gym,
try to tell Dwayne how to do his job,
what I should be doing.
You know,
joking.
No,
he's joking around.
He's just,
uh,
having fun with it.
Relationship this period he would,
his present boss relationship,
you know,
you always hear about these fighters that grew up with uh,
really bad families or a hard upbringing and stuff.
And I've always thought about like,
Dan,
I don't,
I mean live.
Luckily,
luckily I never had any of that stuff and it's crazy that I've wanted to do,
I kind of got into this and it seems like most,
most of the fighters have,
you know,
bad backgrounds for the most part.
Do you know that background can help you,
but it can also could fuck you up like a chip on your shoulder if,
what if you having a bad background because you have a camp ground,
your super balanced.
Sorry.
No,
please.
I think it's someone's,
a vision of how they look at it.
You know,
if you want to look at the fire to heat the house were to burn the house down,
how are you gonna look at that to positively and negatively motivate you.
But I think also everyone's experiences are unique in the amount of trauma they
experienced.
You know,
the amount of abuse they experienced.
It's not uniform.
Yeah.
It's,
you know,
it's hard to tell.
Some guys have gotten out of bad situations that become incredibly motivated and
super dangerous.
And then there's those Tj Dillashaw mother fuckers.
Just like what,
what do you think it is about you that led you to want to be an MMA fighter?
If you ever sat down and thought it out?
What made you so aggressive?
My family for sure.
I have two other brothers.
I'm the middle child.
Um,
my family has always been s anything we do,
we turn into a competition.
I mean,
even even your mom.
Oh yeah.
When we were kids,
we'd be like moms.
I,
my dad and my mom would drive to an event.
We are some wrestling event or whatever to support her kids and we'd both be
there.
We'd pick a car to ride home in and then it'd be a race to get home.
Whoever's with mob wins when we get home or hoovers,
dad's mom,
you know,
we,
when we get home or just any kind of game,
anything we're doing at the house or on vacation,
we've always turned it into a competition and we get pissed when we lose to,
I mean even with family,
you know,
even my mom,
like yeah,
my mom like riding ATVs and getting all aggressive and she's this tiny little
woman and she's the most aggressive out of all of them and it's just kind of
bred me to compete.
And then I wrestled my whole life and I didn't,
I didn't do what I wanted to in wrestling.
I didn't achieve the goals I set myself to.
And so after I graduated,
I just feel like it wasn't done competing,
you know,
like I didn't reach the ultimate greatness.
I wasn't the best I could have been.
Always found that like with competitive athletics,
it's very difficult to do that while you're in college.
And I've always been really impressed by collegic athletes that were able to
maintain high grades and still competed a super high level.
And although it's super admirable,
it's not ideal.
No,
not at all.
So did you feel like there was also an opportunity once you got out of college,
you don't,
didn't have to constitute in your study so much and now you could fully reach
your potential?
And my studies was my competition and I didn't have to worry about anything
else,
but competing obviously make some money to be able to live.
But it was based for,
for my self to be able to fight.
Um,
yeah,
I mean going through school and then also just I,
I'm glad I learned how to pick myself.
I felt like I was peaked wrong and college for wrestling,
it was too much of a grind.
It was too long,
you know?
So I learned a lot through wrestling and which has helped me get to where I'm
at.
It's incredible that wrestling is so difficult that fucking UFC fighters the
highest level say,
man,
I'm glad I'm not wrestling 100% man.
Like all this stuff I do and practice the practice.
I do not want to go to his wrestling.
It's going to be the toughest.
You're going to be the most tired and you're going to be at the most beat up in
wrestling.
Yeah.
It's not the best way to do it,
but it's the best way to develop that in dominant bull mental strength.
I highly recommend getting involved in wrestling if you want to learn the
dedication of martial arts and just a hard work ethic and learning how to
compete.
The mental,
the mental preparation for wrestling is man is nothing else like it.
There's people that think they work hard in.
They're hilarious.
Those people are hilarious.
They really have no idea what hardware kids,
if you've,
I'm,
I'm not bullshitting.
Even if you'd done Jujitsu,
even if you've done kickboxing,
my one of the hardest times I've ever worked out was high school wrestling.
Once he's in a high school wrestling,
I remember we were doing shit where I was waking up in the morning and it would
hurt my legs to stand up and be like,
ah,
my legs were on fire and I'd be walking to the bedroom.
I was 16 or 15 or whatever the fuck I was.
I was like,
ah,
my fucking legs are killing me.
I'd be in class,
I'd be exhausted.
And then I knew looking at the clock,
oh motherfucker,
couple of hours from now we're going to go to war again.
Oh,
in college I'd be doing morning practice where they're doing strength
conditioning or runs like intense runs before classes before at six in the
morning and we're doing this.
And then we go to class.
You know,
you have two or three classes depending on your day of the week.
And then you have a two hour practices he's getting on with the classes,
you know?
Or he might have a night class after practice,
you know,
and homework.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
And then homework,
you know,
so research,
homework,
fucking pile of books and shit.
It definitely does.
That's what these guys are so successful now.
But look at guys like harm.
Yay.
Look guys.
The cornea that,
those high level wrestlers,
not just his wrestling,
but that sort of focus and dedication that those guys have and that,
that knowledge of how to win,
how to compete.
Remember that Matt Lindland if he's the most,
the most technically sound guy,
but he knew how to fight.
He was a Gamer.
He knew how to compete.
Anything.
No doubt.
It's,
it's amazing when you,
uh,
you see how many great amateur wrestlers have gone on to be great MMA class.
Why?
It's so unfortunate to see these restaurant programs get cut too terrible.
Cal,
cal state,
Florida,
my rest of that,
it doesn't have wrestling team anymore.
We're trying to get it back.
But it's like to teach someone life skills.
Like wrestling is the best way to,
I mean one of the sports in general is the best way to do it and there's no way
she could wrestling.
It's communism,
terrorists and one.
So what it is,
it's anti American.
If they have money for Lacrosse,
they should have some fucking money for wrestling's.
How can you play Lacrosse and this day and age and have straight looking at that
and that costs and stuff is just smiling while you're running around with his
ball.
And now it's a title nine to a man.
I mean,
I have nothing against a females doing sports,
but to cancel a program,
just because you don't have an equal amount of females doing male sports,
they do a dance program instead of wrestling.
Like we have a dance program at cal state Fullerton instead of arresting,
plus the vacation of America,
Tj Dillashaw on Duane Ludwig,
especially in California.
Man,
like it's not like in the west coat.
I mean the Midwest wrestling is huge,
you know,
but out here it's just,
it's not as popular,
so it gets thrown away.
I think that,
I personally believe that not just wrestling,
but martial arts programs should be mandatory for all boys growing up.
And girls too.
I think girls should at least have rudimentary ideas of self defense.
Just make our country bad ass.
No one wants to mess with us.
Survival of the fittest and want to do that,
but it will also cut the bullying way the fuck down.
People would be more confident.
I'd be scared.
People would be less geared and people will be less inclined to just fuck with
people.
There's a lot of times when people are fucking with people,
they're doing it because they're insecure and they want some sort of,
yeah,
they want some sort of an outlet for sure.
That's a big aspect of it.
But they also want some sort of validation.
But if you can get that in the gym,
you don't need that out out anywhere else and you can,
you can be more relaxed.
It's like you were talking about how hard you guys go in the gym and how
everybody's super competitive.
But I've seen you guys outside of the gym and everybody's super friendly and not
just to each other but to other people that you encountered too because there's
no need to release.
You just know backed up,
pent up frustrated energy.
And there's also like this,
there's more confidence.
Yeah.
Well I was telling Duane before we got here,
I don't know what brought it up,
but during college days or high school,
I would have no problem getting in a fight in high school and,
and beaten some kid up outside on the street.
Cause I didn't like him,
you know?
But now that I'm doing a marshal,
I mean wrestling is martial arts,
but now that I'm doing like a full on fighting martial arts and I have utmost
confidence in myself,
it's like I don't want it to go and beat someone up.
I could really hurt someone.
You know what I mean?
Like I don't want to do it.
And that's him in the cage getting paid for it.
Yeah.
And then you're doing it against pro athletes that knows what he's getting
himself into.
The difference between competing in an assault too.
That's something we owe.
Sport is so violent.
You know you were involved in a violent sport,
Tj Dillashaw but you're such a nice guy.
Yes.
And but it's also the most extreme test you can put yourself to.
Sports made me nicer.
I believe that it really has,
this sport has leveled me out,
made me a whole lot nicer than I used to be I think.
I think in,
in college and in high school I was a bit meaner of a person than I am now.
Do you think it's because you burned it out or because you have more confidence?
Like,
what do you attribute it to?
I just learning to be,
I don't know,
a little bit more level headed and just uh,
just matured it out.
Matured.
Yeah.
And then I feel like if I would've been involved in this,
even at a younger age,
I would have matured a lot faster as well.
Yeah,
I think so too.
I think that for boys especially,
that's the only,
I mean obviously I'm male self worth in,
uh,
and what it takes to be,
to be that person and then afterwards you just kind of,
I don't know,
you just don't have a chip on your shoulder anymore.
You know,
you've been in the gym let not as much aggression,
testosterone as possible and then you get on the street and he's like,
you don't need to,
you know,
you don't have that pent up aggression.
Yeah.
I think a lot of people go through life.
A lot of guys go through life with that.
What does that sound?
Is that your fingers?
What does that,
that's probably me moving your legs so much,
Huh?
Sorry,
carry on.
No,
no,
no.
There was like a scratchy scratchy in here that,
uh,
I heard it.
But that extra pent up aggression,
it's like gives guys like a trigger.
They start reacting to things.
But if you train training,
you're done training.
Like I always say like after the gym,
nothing bothers me.
Nothing like literally nothing.
Especially if you sparred like people could be yelling at you and you'd be like,
please don't yell at me.
I got to go.
You know,
it's like,
especially down here with all the traffic everyone should be doing.
I know a lot less road rage.
Just go rolling.
You should just put on drills,
little bit of ecstasy and everybody cared.
Commissioner titanium is a happy place.
Just a little bit.
A tiny bit is going to be all right folks.
To see martial arts,
one of the other pick one,
they can figure out how to make a car that gives you a little ecstasy as you
driving just the tiniest amount of ecstasy like they've sown.
Studies have shown that one microgram of ectasy in your air supply keeps you
from being in toxified,
but instead of being intoxicated,
you have a wonderful time during your day and you're more productive and
friendly to everybody.
That's why Mercedes Benz,
those things to go through the roof,
dude,
everyone will be buying them and be cranking them.
They're not a turn it up a little bit more.
[inaudible] sees your car got in it.
I feel like that's what moody,
New Moody's for me,
man.
I love new mood,
like new movies.
One of my favorite products,
the ANA does it.
Like that's the one I can feel the most difference with.
His new mood and t plus.
Yeah,
I love new mood too.
And anybody who's interested in five HTP supplements,
which is what new mood is,
you've gotta be really careful that you're not on Ssri is if you're on any sort
of antidepressants,
Zoloft,
things along those lines.
Uh,
Serotonin reuptake inhibitors,
I forget how the actual,
what it stands for,
but that's,
you can have something called Serotonin Syndrome.
We have too much serotonin.
I like the new mood elevates your serotonin and then so do these uh,
these drugs as well.
But uh,
for people that might be too happy then or why our face probably dangerous.
It's like your body take too much new moon.
No,
no,
I don't think so.
I mean you'd have to take a lot,
you'd have to take a lot.
If I take four pills at a shot and I'll on a like a stressful day,
I'll do that twice a crazy day.
If I go,
I have a lot of shit going on and I've never had any negative effects at all.
But I think if you're going to be careful,
you should probably take less than I do.
I think I'm fucking around.
I think about,
I take four,
four alphabets before the fights to y z two,
four Alpha brain before every show.
One before,
before,
before we got in here too.
I take four Alpha brain for every comedy show before every broadcast I take
four.
Yeah.
Now that I feel like I've noticed more of a longterm then like right away like
Alpha brain,
I've noticed like my concentration and stuff from longterm,
I don't notice it like that day but like over like a month.
But like damn,
I picked up stuff a lot faster.
It's a subtle increase and it used to be a little bit more potent.
But uh,
we were having problems that people were getting headaches from it.
There was a larger number of people where
I wasn't getting headaches.
Now we have to take eight of them cause he has lowered the dose.
Well we've talked about um,
no I,
I still feel a big,
big difference from these and the clinical trial that we did,
the double blind,
that was what this,
this particular formula,
but I still think that we should release a fucking hyper version for people were
savages.
Oh you want to get crazy even if you don't want her own skull and crossbones on
it.
If we can't release it,
can I at least get something?
We can get you something.
Well,
I think this is just the beginning of this sort of science of,
uh,
of nootropics and they're coming up with all sorts of different combinations.
These things Paraskeva town.
I want that stuff to be like,
oh,
that shit,
my favorite.
Limitless.
Love that movie,
man.
That's America and a nutshell.
Everybody's wants to be a lazy fuck that you take a pill and then said your
suits man.
Gotta work for it.
Isn't it funny though,
how many God damn movies there are about a dumb person all sudden becomes super
smart and figures the whole fucking world out.
Like John Travolta when you got hit by lightning?
That's right.
All of a sudden these fucking learning Portuguese and shit.
Yeah,
that was a good one.
Trying to get struck by lightning and stuffs like it'd be smarter.
Well,
you know what does work with some things like people have,
like I have a friend and her son got in a motorcycle accident and then he got a
head injury and became super artistic after the motorcycle injury.
Yeah.
So we do need to get hit in the head.
Well,
Zach Science,
that's the problem.
Sam Kinison got hit and they had a,
when he was a kid too,
he got hit by a truck.
Oh,
I heard about this.
Yeah.
And it fucking switch.
You'd be like a normal,
calm,
shy kid.
And then he got hit by a truck and I'll sign
this fucking wild,
impulsive maniac.
That's crazy.
Honestly.
Yeah.
Well,
head injuries are just very strange.
It's very strange.
The reactions that a,
that head injuries have,
you know,
people have had car accidents and then become gay.
Oh Wow.
Yeah.
Really.
No Way.
I might have no,
I'm not feeling no,
no.
Hold on a second.
Head trauma turns back it up.
No,
I don't think so.
Some guy who was,
who was gay and it's used as an excuse.
That's fine.
I'm not judging it.
Rugby player wakes up gay after a stroke.
Wow.
He had a stroke and then he woke up and he was gay.
Someone took care of him when he was barely rugby player has a stroke after
freak gym accident,
let me up gay and becomes a hairdresser.
That's just as to me,
whatever.
I mean he's gained.
Yeah,
it's cool.
Whatever.
You know,
this is that guy earlier,
but so the fuck does not look like a rugby player either.
But I mean he doesn't even make up an excuse of getting hit in the head to be
gaming and just whoever your gates,
you don't know,
maybe really did have a stroke and woke up gay,
but he used to look like straight as fuck.
He looked straight.
We'll,
you know,
there was um,
there was a drug called reequip that uh,
an Irish man won a settlement of,
I believe it was like 600,000 US dollars because this drug turned him gay and
into a gambling addict.
She was having unsafe sex and he was,
uh,
he was going like meeting people online and getting fucking crazy with dude's
and do a bunch of gay shit.
And he was a family man.
Married guy won.
He Won.
How do you prove that?
That's a very good question,
TJ.
Dillashaw I like how you think fucking know man.
But not only did they prove it,
I mean this was against Glaxo Klein to Glaxo clients.
Smith,
the big pharmaceutical companies.
Yeah,
they're the ones who lost.
So it was their lawyers lost this case.
It was so much evidence here,
I'll pull it up.
Re-Equip this.
There must be so much fucking evidence.
Turns a man Gai.
Wow,
that is crazy.
There's so much evidence that they actually had to give him money,
which was an amazing,
yeah,
he won 160,000 pounds,
which is roughly somewhere around,
what's the,
that weird l looking thing?
It's not a pound.
I have no,
the one shore.
Um,
anyway,
whatever the,
the,
the amount of this was,
it was,
it was $160,000.
Way Too much.
He took care of it.
So 160 bucks,
he shouldn't get paid for them.
Nothing.
Somebody got,
somebody got the manipulatives.
Well,
he had Parkinson's and so this was a Parkinson's medication and it turned him
into a gay sex and gambling addict.
Amazing impulsive control systems.
And this is where it gets really weird,
including compulsive behaviors.
They ever been.
Reports of patients experiencing intense urges to gamble,
increased sexual urges and other intense urges and the inability to control
those urges while taking one or more of the medications that increase central
dope.
Dope.
It's dope.
Amid jet,
uh,
Minard chick dopaminergic,
dopaminergic menergy tones that are generally used for the treatment of
Parkinson's disease.
So this is an restless leg syndrome.
When you see when dudes like you can't stop moving their legs.
That's my parking sky.
Does he have any daughters?
Is that a job?
Should have worked on that one a little bit more for you.
Let it loose skin sons.
He had Parkinson's.
Oh,
you're so retarded.
It doesn't work.
He can't keep,
keep trying.
He's like,
come on guys.
Parking son wears his daughters when they get it,
they still want to fuck.
I thought it was funny,
but I think,
well you missed it.
Please don't encourage him.
We both passed it.
There was nothing there.
The um,
the idea that a,
that a drug could do that too though,
is pretty fucking shocking drug.
It turns you into acting like a lot of other people in the world.
Well,
not just acting like a lot of the people in the world,
but you were a normal guy,
was a control of your urges and then all of a sudden you're just flying off the
handle meet and dudes online.
They're just,
there you go,
Brian.
We should do that as a test.
Just get you on this shit.
I would love to try it.
[inaudible] he would totally do it.
He'd be the best Guinea pig.
We give him a monthly budget and a videographer and a nice,
it would be at like Dick.
It'd be easy.
That's the thing in the rural,
if you just craved it instead of having to deal with all this nonsense.
That's what I'm saying.
Damn.
I mean,
look,
everybody wants to say there's something wrong with,
with being gay,
but you live and you die and if you're straight,
you look at gang go,
oh,
I don't want that.
But guess what?
If you're straight,
you look at if you're gay,
rather you look at the trait and go,
I don't want that.
What you like is what you like and if you like gay,
it would be awesome to be gay.
Yeah,
there's spots.
I had doctors ready to go do my physicals and stuff for the fight.
They say,
why are you fighting?
Like,
why are you doing this?
Like fuck man.
I don't know.
But it's fun.
Yeah.
My levels of testosterone,
I think,
well if you go down to Santa Monica Boulevard,
if you're a gay guy,
there's like a one stop shop.
You just,
you just take your shirt off and just walk to the crowd and to just start
blowing you mean?
That's what I hear.
That's what I hear very different because it's all Yang because Yang,
Yang,
Yang.
There's no Yin's like there's no like,
oh,
I don't know.
You just want to use me.
None of that.
They're using each other.
They're just fucking blasted each other.
They're having a great time.
They understand each other.
There's no confusion,
there's no navigate.
You know,
like navigating relationship with a woman is like putting rubber gloves on in
the dark and putting your hands into one of those incubation tubes and try to do
a Rubik's cube.
Like what?
I can't see what the fuck's going on here.
You have to like take their word for what is happening here.
Oh,
you're upset that I went out with my friends.
okay.
I guess.
No more friends.
You my friend.
How are you?
What's going on here?
That's you.
We don't know how they think.
I think I got a good Rubik's cube.
I was like,
dude,
well you got a good one.
That's the key.
Get a Rubik's cube that you could figure out.
But dudes,
no one dude's,
they're like,
oh you like Dick Guy Pod
fucking,
they know what's going on.
I like,
we both liked each other.
They Bang it out.
He's more easy.
You were offered this drug.
If you weren't married,
would you try it?
You know,
I'd have to be committed because you see women can dance back and forth from the
world of gay and straight with an effortless finesse.
They can.
They can easily go back and forth.
Not only that,
it makes them more attractive.
They can say things like,
[inaudible] like to talk about this.
But I was gay for like a year,
shut up for a year.
I had a girlfriend and you know,
I just was like,
men are assholes.
I'm done.
And you're like,
your dick is like kind of just a raging missile in your parents.
Like where is she?
Tell her to come stay with us.
You know,
that was the first thought in every guy for sure.
For sure.
She's like,
it's okay.
It doesn't even bother me.
If you came home and you find your girlfriend eating pussy,
you wouldn't be like,
what the fuck to be like,
oh,
what's going on here?
Just take your clothes off and come in the room.
Like,
Hey,
as long as the girls,
the girlfriend is not like all jealous and fucking plotty look,
you better keep it away from me.
Oh my gosh.
Someone's ruin the party
as long as she's friendly too.
But if a girl comes home and her boyfriend is stuck in a car,
that's a bummer.
You come home and your boyfriend is blown the plumber,
that is a fucking straight bummer,
you know?
But if you came home and like you know your wife had went to fucking lunch with
some chick was in aerobics class and they're eating each other out when you
walked through the door.
It's really not that big of a deal.
It's a little surprising.
Like,
Whoa,
this is crazy.
The accident mail sacks is a very different act.
It's very,
so,
no,
I wouldn't take that pill
to answer your question.
Would you take it you think you would take it?
No,
no,
no.
Girls are better.
They're prettier.
They smell better.
Would be interesting to try it though if there was a a a a serum,
you know what I mean?
Like I like Dick.
That's so weird.
All right,
nevermind.
That was weird though.
Yeah,
I wouldn't mind curious.
Cool.
I wouldn't mind being that girl for a day.
This is what I say.
If I was,
if I,
if there's a possibility that you could go into someone's mind,
like say this,
say if you,
you and your girlfriend got together and you went into a machine and you swapped
positions,
like she became the girl and you became the guy.
Like you had all your knowledge of life,
but all of a sudden you thought like a girl and you wanted to get fucked and you
want to get fucked by you because she's,
you know,
and you are her.
So you liked boys and you liked you and that would be a way that you could be
gay but not be gay because he'd be gay for yourself.
So you would switch positions with your girlfriend or,
or what,
so you have her thoughts.
She would be banging you doggy style.
You're like,
wow,
this does hurt my service.
This is kind of annoying.
She wasn't lying.
She could be,
she can feel what it's like to get head and going,
oh,
now I know why you're always trying to get me to do this.
This is pretty awesome.
She's like,
I,
it's odd.
I like it better when I'm looking at it crazy.
I like it better when I'm looking at you doing this.
I never would have imagined that.
Now I know why you're always creeping me out.
I need to invent this machine just to make the relationship better and make
everyone's relationship.
Well,
there's a problem now man.
There's this weird competition between men and women.
There's US versus them,
you know,
and there's a bunch of sneaky fucks that sneak on the other side.
Both men and women.
There's a bunch of women down to hang with men.
You know,
this is a girl.
She like to come over your house and no,
she can watch sports with us.
Yeah.
Fuck she can.
Goddamn trader,
gender trader over here sneaking around collecting data to bring back to the
data.
And that's the same way with men and men who you know like the White Knights
like Stan this,
there's white knights that start shit that there's nothing like a man and a
woman could be having a disagreement,
like a calm disagreement and some dickhead.
We'll walk up and go,
is he bothering you?
Is there a problem here?
Like oh you grow sack of shit.
How dare you now people not even raising their foot wall.
I saw is you being a dick to a beautiful woman.
Like there's,
there's a lot of those guys out there,
they'll insert themselves whether it's verbally into an internet situation or
there it's physically in a bar.
Just nosy cunts are totally out of line that we'll pretend that you're being
aggressive and you know,
I've seen it happen with a girl.
It's like get the fuck outta here.
No we're just talking about that so you're not,
you're not a part of this.
I came over to help you and the girl was like,
I don't need your fucking house.
Like what are you doing man?
And then the dude,
but the dude had his mouth open and dude was like,
are you fucking serious?
I can't believe this guy came over.
That's super common.
Super common that sanctimonious Shithead dudes will step in as the White Knight.
Those guys are disgusting cause they have this like fucking moral high ground.
Like almost like they're going to come over and rescue someone.
It doesn't mean it's like,
do you remember
back at the same time exactly.
Trying to sneak it on your chick.
Exactly.
You know what I mean?
Like exactly.
This guy's a dick.
Leave him for me.
Come on,
let's go.
Do you remember those?
A Guardian Angel dudes.
Do you remember those guys?
They would wear berets and this fucking fight crime and shit.
Yeah.
Do you remember that?
Yeah,
the,
well they found out here's what happened to him.
One of them faked a rape that he helped a rescue.
Someone,
you know,
he like,
he faked it and then you know,
stepped in and saved the day and they caught him and it's like everybody was
like,
what the fuck are you doing?
The guy became like a radio,
a guy who was like doing,
you know,
a radio show for a while.
But those kind of guys,
they would be like walking around like looking for people to save.
Sometimes they would be like directing traffic.
I remember I was in Boston and I was in traffic and I'm,
I'm sitting there at a red light and this dude's a guardian angel and he's got
the baret on.
He's dressed like a fucking superhero and I look over at him and I'm,
and I'm with my friend,
I'm like,
look at this guy over here,
what is going to go on?
And I look over the guy and the guy's like,
fuck you.
He's giving me the finger.
And just because I was looking at him like,
dude,
you're wearing an outfit from another era.
Like you have a bra on Sir.
Like are you a poet?
And in France,
like what are you doing?
Who are they still around?
Safety.
Patrol.
Yeah.
That's the guy.
That guy in the middle.
He's the guy that fake the rape.
Yeah,
I guess.
But they,
these baret wearing fucking shit heads.
I'm wandering the streets.
So strange.
I mean not naughty bus.
The naughty,
I'll cancel.
I need that shit.
The Guardian Angels countdown with the Goddamn and listening to people in every
position.
Then of course overall the overall mission of that is good.
It's cool though.
Yeah.
Well if it was legit,
yeah,
and maybe it is in some circumstances,
but what I'm going back
to is those fucking white knight ass,
all those guys who pretend pretend is a nice problem.
You see it online to traders,
you fucking pussies.
You're the opposite of clinics.
Wouldn't all his best movies.
That's what you've heard.
Way Little Bitches,
sad pitches with,
with weak sperm.
No one wants any of it to the martial arts.
They'd be even more respectful human beings.
They would have more confidence.
They wouldn't have to take that sneaky move,
the sneaky move.
We're trying to paint other men as a victim or other men as the aggressor when
they're not.
That's a common thing with guys.
I see that or did you know,
and then there's also,
there's guys that do fucking suck and this guys that we have to call out that
men have to go,
this guy's a fucking cunt.
You know that the guys that are ruining it for other men because they treat
women like shit.
There's that too,
but it's hard to distinguish when you got your fake ass white nights out there
muddying the water.
They're ruining it.
Just peeing in the pool.
Good judge of character,
cry and cry and Walter the judges.
But that's the thing,
right?
The judge of character had society.
Those are women and there's a bunch of old ladies.
Those ladies are very friendly.
How dare you see,
that's the thing about women's groups,
man.
You don't worried about them beating people up like fucking guardian angels or
Hell's angels.
He,
you know,
he could run into a bunch of dudes.
[inaudible] you're in a possible ass kicking stereo red hats.
What are those bitches going to do?
It's very few.
Very few riots started by Red Hat women
you get out of my yard.
So this fight,
let's go back to this five round fight.
What,
what is the next day like after a fight like that?
What kind of injuries you dealing with kind of soreness?
Are you dealing with
my,
luckily all offensive,
uh,
injuries,
you know,
like my right hand was sore.
It's just feeling better now.
My right elbow,
left Shin,
right Shane kind of deal just from throwing strikes.
You know,
I got,
I got cut a little tiny cut on my head,
but for the most part feeling good.
You know,
I didn't take too much damage at all and uh,
you know,
a little bruise and my,
my nose always gets kind of,
it's just always in the way.
But um,
yeah it felt great man.
Do you see these injuries like Anderson Silva,
Tyrone Spong,
these leg check leg break injuries,
which is crazy to see two of them in the course of a few months by super high
level fighters.
Um,
well Duane I should ask you this,
probably as a coach,
what do you would attribute that to and how can guys prevent that from
happening?
Cause it's some of the most horrific shit I've ever seen.
I don't know if it was a preexisting injury already.
If they had an injury going into the fight over happened then or if it's just
blocking wrong and not turn the toes out,
make sure line up the shins are buffering the blow or if they went into it.
So it's a couple know x factors there.
But you know,
I don't know.
I mean if you,
if think you seen it more and more than it would be something that's happening
during the injury camp.
And I think that those just to freak accidents.
Well it's happened.
Well it happened at Carlos condit to someone kicked him,
they broke their ankle also on a king of the cage fight.
But I'm not sure to be honest man.
I just have to,
the hill was the court he'll also,
yeah,
he was a real tall skinny guy.
Yup.
So we sort of attributed to that.
Like he was one 55 when he was so maybe cutting too much weight,
cutting too much weight you think has an impact on bone density body.
I don't know.
But Anderson didn't really cut too much weight,
did he?
He's,
he cuts way.
He gets pretty heavy.
And Tyrone Spong definitely caught weight when you made that Gloria.
I don't know though.
I know he caught it cause they were talking about it because he had two fights.
Go Con Saki had two fights would go con Saki won the first fight.
He fought Nathan Corbett and knocked him out with a,
not knocked him out,
but he hit him with a left hook and his,
his ears started bleeding real bad.
They stopped that fight in the first round.
He blew out his eardrum and then so he got a first round stoppage.
But then Tyrone Spong fought this Brazilian cat and went three hard rounds with
them and then they fought again that night.
I have a problem with that.
I think that I love glory and I'm so happy that bring in high level kickboxing
to television,
but I really think they should abandon that fighting twice in one night.
I think it's fucking dangerous.
That's the worst thing in your brain.
He's double concussions.
So you've got to come,
you can still fight on concussion and you're getting your second one so much
worse for your brain.
And it's not even if one guy got a concussion in the first round of their,
their fight fought two more rounds was like out of it.
And then an hour later it's got a fight in the final match and the other guy won
his first fight with one punch.
He didn't receive any damage at all.
Just because you know,
they both had to fight doesn't mean that it's an even situation going into the
final fight.
It's absolutely not even,
which makes it kind of interesting for the folks at home.
But I think when you're dealing with the highest level of combat athletes,
it's a disservice to them.
Make them
like hi and a half to do that on ultimate fighter.
I mean,
you do get longer breaks,
but man,
it's crunched into six weeks.
If you go into a fight and get cut,
you might not,
they might not even let you fight,
you know,
like,
it's,
uh,
everything's got to work together for that show too.
I mean,
not always.
The best athlete wins that show because of so many x factors going into the
fight.
Yeah.
And hand injuries and they just go back to a game planning as well.
The first couple of rounds or first couple of fights and I said,
lay not showing to put everything out of the toolbox is fighting.
It was just say fights to see what to the end.
You know,
one of the kids on this season,
ultimate fighter,
uh,
I think,
how do you pronounce the last name?
Spawn.
Oh,
the kid to have the good knockout to get in the house.
Good knock out to get in the house.
And then he had a second fight and just wiped very conservatively and people
were just going crazy and booing him and getting mad at him.
And Dana said it was one of the worst fights it's ever seen.
Do you have a problem with that?
Does that drive you nuts when you know the actual scenario inside the house,
you know that you have to get through that and this idea that you're supposed to
throw caution to the wind and your future,
there's throw it on a whim just to make it more exciting.
Yeah,
I mean the guy is smart.
He's looking towards the future is really smart.
I mean,
you know,
a lot of people don't look at it that way.
They don't realize how the Fao Fastest show his filmed.
It's filling in six weeks.
You fight a week later,
most likely.
Sometimes you'll get a little bit longer break,
but my last two fights within five days of each other.
It's crazy.
Yeah.
It's incredibly difficult to do.
And in any other situation it probably likely wouldn't get sanctioned.
No.
Yeah.
Call.
You know,
if you were fighting in the UFC and you fought a three round hard fight and then
they said,
oh,
there's going to fight another three on a hard fight in a week,
he'd be like,
he's going to what?
Yeah.
Can you imagine if somebody from this past weekend,
let's pick a fight or Damien Maia.
Damien Maia had a three round scrap this past weekend.
If he had to go,
and you know,
this week someone fell out and they said,
well,
Damien Maia is going to fight this weekend in Vegas.
You'd be like,
what the fuck are you talking about?
The Vegas Athletic Commission would be like the fuck he is,
but somehow or another on a,
an extended show where it's a tournament format,
like glory,
they're going to fight in a night.
That's right.
That's nuts.
They wouldn't let you fight the next day,
but they'll let you fight an hour later and no matter what,
no matter how the fight goes,
even if you win like easily,
he still gets suspended 30 45 days.
I don't know how the fuck is a guy fighting a two round war,
three round war and kickboxing and then going to fight again.
Then I guess that goes back to how they used to have like 12 round seal
kickboxing matches and then we separate 15 round boxes go and then just breaking
it up.
It's a pair of the same format is,
but it's not because you,
you're never getting cold brakes.
Yeah.
That break when you get cold and everything chills out.
Right?
Yeah.
That's a terrible,
I fought three times.
The only time I ever fought kickboxing.
I fought three times in one night.
Oh Wow.
And I had an hour between the second fight and the third fight and you try to
fire up again.
You've already fought twice that day.
You're beating the fuck down.
That's a wrestling tournament.
It's very hard.
You've got yeah,
aspect.
Also the wrestling tournament though,
the only difference being that wrestling,
you're not taking head blows.
I worry about guys and glory getting concussed in the first round and then
making it through somehow and then fighting in the finals and getting your head
kicked into oblivion.
You know?
I really do worry about that.
I just don't think it's the right way.
I think they've got such a great thing.
They're putting high level kickboxing on TV.
You're getting,
you see all these Moyie Thai grades,
you're getting to see all these like amazing,
amazing fighters and fights,
but the situation with a tournament I just think is archaic.
I think they didn't need to abandon that shit.
It's just tickle fights each night.
So more to tournament MMA.
You just know mean when they used to do that shit and pride and they should do
that shit in the UFC.
Even playing fields.
I liked that better for sure.
Yeah.
We must people in terms it shouldn't win them.
No,
I shouldn't say shouldn't want them,
but they shouldn't win them.
You're you.
You're right.
It's there.
Shouldn't win them.
It's not fair.
It's,
it's too crazy.
It's like,
yes,
it's interesting.
Yes.
It's entertaining.
It's fascinating.
But it's unconscionable knowing what we know now about injuries and about damage
that a body takes to do that just for entertainment.
It's cause it's not,
it's not as simple as you're risking all on one fight.
You train for eight weeks,
boom.
You're in the match.
It's not,
it's two t two fights in a day.
You Poussey
commentating on hopscotch.
You,
I'm just saying,
I'm just saying.
Yeah,
definitely want to take the of safety and belonging to account for sure.
Duane Ludwig and Tj Dillashaw.
I think we cleaned up a lot of things to think.
We've solved a lot of problems.
Judging problems,
training problems.
Listen man,
I can't say enough.
Uh,
congratulations to you guys guys.
Awesome.
Awesome job and awesome potential.
It's an awesome things to come,
TJ.
Dillashaw yeah,
well I can't believe it,
man.
I mean it's,
it's impossible to say how impressive the whole thing has been for you.
You're living the dream man.
Congratulations.
Bantam weight,
motherfucking champion of the world.
Sounds good,
Paul.
Tj.
Dillashaw.
Alright,
thanks to our sponsor.
Thanks to Naturebox,
uh,
go to naturebox naturebox.
We'll get George Thompson,
go to naturebox.com forward slash Rogan and get 50% off of your first box.
Thanks also to onnit.com go to o n n I t use the Codeword Rogan and save 10% off
any and all supplements.
And right now,
um,
does,
uh,
is today for 48 hours.
Today is June 2nd,
Monday,
June 2nd,
and you have 16% off of everything.
That's companies.
We're number 16.
I use the code word June 48.
So that's for 48 hours.
June 48 16% off.
He's got one day and 20 hours,
almost two days as of right now as of three o'clock.
I better hurry up and get on there.
All you dirty for on it.
All right,
we'll see you tomorrow.
I'm much love to everybody.
Follow Tj Dillashaw on Twitter and Dwayne Bang 20 Bank.
Calm Dwayne,
Bang.
Calm on Twitter as well.
All right.
Big Love Wa because Wa see you soon.
Yeah.